Im Hinblick darauf, dass die Aufnahmefähigkeit eines Teils eines Teils der Mitglieder des Hauses offenbar nachhaltig eingeschränkt ist, bin ich bin ich durchaus der Meinung, dass wir eine Unterhaltung über die rechts- und innenpolitischen Fragen, die hier entschieden werden müssen, bei nächster Gelegenheit in einer etwas verständigeren Atmosphäre fortsetzen sollten. Herr Kollege Kleinert, Ihre Redezeit ist abgelaufen. Wir mussten zum Schluss kommen. Herr Präsident, ich bedauere, dass du dies...
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 66. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove, hallo und ich begrüße euch zu einer weiteren Folge in dem Podcast, wo man alles erfährt, was man für das Leben braucht. Und ganz wichtig, und das haben wir alle schon vermisst, sind natürlich praktische Informationen. Da hatten wir zwar zuletzt schon so einiges, aber diesmal erstreckt sich das Thema auf praktische Informationen zum Mitgestalten. Und zwar ist die Rede hier ganz konkret von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, dem Staat, in dem vielleicht jetzt nicht alle von euch leben und walten, aber doch sicherlich der eine oder andere angehören wird. Und da das ein sehr kompliziertes System ist, oder zumindest den Eindruck macht, dass es das ist, vielleicht ist es dem ja auch gar nicht so, wollte ich da mal etwas eintauchen. Und mit mir eintauchen, mein Tauchpartner am heutigen Abend, ist Falk, Falk Lüke, hallo. Hallo Tim. Du bist studierter Politologe, wie du so schön formuliert hast. Das heißt, man studiert Politologeologie.
Man studiert eigentlich Politikwissenschaft, kann allerdings auch Politologie dazu sagen.
Das ist sozusagen ein Mainstream-Begriff.
Es ist ein Begriff, der lange Zeit sehr umstritten war. Man kann darüber diskutieren, ob es besser politische Wissenschaft, Politikwissenschaft oder Politologie heißt.
Politologie klingt so ein bisschen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie klingt denn das eigentlich? Klingt so ein bisschen, dass man nicht so genau weiß, worum es eigentlich geht.
Na ja, die Lehre von der Politik.
Okay, die Lehre von der Politik. Und was lernt man da so?
Was lernt man dort so? Man lernt, was Politik eigentlich ist, wo der Unterschied ist zwischen dem politischen und dem privaten, wo Politik überhaupt anfängt, wo sie aufhört, wie Politik gestaltet werden kann, was die Grundlagen der Politik sind, welche Theorien es gibt, wie Politik funktioniert und auch einiges, vielleicht auch Praktisches, kann man da auch mal lernen.
Kann man dann, also ich meine, ist das sozusagen die Grundausbildung für einen Politiker?
Es gibt interessanterweise tatsächlich immer mehr Politiker, zumindest im Deutschen Bundestag, die selber auch Politikwissenschaft studiert haben. Früher war das Verhältnis etwas anders. Da waren es in erster Linie Juristen und Lehrer, also Lehrämtler. Heutzutage hat man immer noch, ich glaube die größte Gruppe sind immer noch die Juristen gefolgt, immer noch von den Lehrämtlern, aber die Politologen haben ganz schön aufgeholt. Es gibt einige davon, ich glaube der bekannteste ist eigentlich Rudolf Scharping. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das so ein unglaublich positives Beispiel dafür ist, ob man Politologen zu einem Politiker machen sollte. Man kann auf die Art also ganz schön baden gehen.
Du meinst, weil er irgendwie vom Fahrrad fällt dann oder was?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Rudolf Scharping diese Legislaturperiode überhaupt noch im Bundestag sitzt. Ich vermute ja, es würde mich wundern, wenn nicht.
Echt, ist er noch dabei? Ich dachte, er wäre gar nicht mehr dabei.
Ich glaube, das kann man noch nachschauen.
Zumindest wird nicht über ihn mehr geredet.
Er hat auf jeden Fall kein Amt inne, was in gewisser Weise eine herausragende Bedeutung hätte. Sagen wir es so, aber das war ja auch nach diversen Geschichten.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Politologen im Bundestag, außer Rudolf Scharping.
Ja natürlich, es gibt einige Politologen im Bundestag.
Und ist das dann sozusagen die Drittmeister-Vertretung?
Ich meine, es wäre momentan die Drittmeister, wer es ganz genau wissen will. Es gibt eine Berufestatistik, die findet sich auf bundestag.de. Sie ist insofern ein bisschen schwierig zu lesen, als dass tatsächlich einige unserer Volksvertreter das gemacht haben, also unserer sogenannten Volksvertreter oder auch Tatsächlichen. Dazu kommen wir aber später. Sie haben ein Doppelstudium absolviert, ganz häufig. Also nicht ganz häufig, aber einige davon. Schönes Beispiel hat der Doblak Melin. Sie ist promoviert als Juristin, hat auch Jura studiert, aber hat aber auch Politikwissenschaft studiert. Das legt sich schon ein bisschen her bei ihr. Ich glaube, sie ist jetzt das 37. Jahr im Bundestag. Irgendwie sowas.
Aber warum sind denn so viele Lehrer dabei?
Das darfst du mich nicht so genau fragen. Also bei den Lehrern, es könnte vielleicht daran liegen, dass sie das geringste Berufsrisiko haben, hinterher wieder in ihren Beruf zu kommen als Beamte. Das könnte gut sein.
Ach so, du meinst, dass es am wenigsten risikoreich ist, sich mal in den Bundestag wählen zu lassen und danach immer wieder die Möglichkeit...
Ach so, okay, die Rückkehrmöglichkeit ist für einen Lehrer einfacher.
Aber Beamte sind ja an sich sehr stark vertreten.
Beamte sind insgesamt relativ stark vertreten, ja.
Aber die meisten davon sind Lehrer, was sind dann die anderen?
Je nachdem, du kannst natürlich auch klassischer Verwaltungsbeamter sein oder ähnliches. Du darfst dann allerdings nicht aktiv gleichzeitig ein politisches Amt und ein Verwaltungsamt bekleiden innerhalb der normalen Verwaltungskarriere. Fühlt ein bisschen zu weit ab vom Schuss. Aber natürlich, wie gesagt, Beamte haben natürlich den grundsätzlichen Vorteil, dass sie jederzeit zurückkehren können. Wenn du jetzt ein Selbstständiger bist und eine eigene Firma hast, hast du natürlich ein Problem, wenn du jetzt für eine gewisse Zeit deine Firma liegen lässt, um dann nach einer Legislaturperiode, zwei Legislaturperioden diese Firma wieder weiterzuführen. Das funktioniert ganz häufig nicht so gut.
Das ist ja eigentlich ganz schön doof.
Ja, und es gibt auch einige Bestrebungen, das zu ändern oder auch nicht zu ändern oder wie auch immer. Da gibt es zumindest einige Leute, die sich sehr viele Gedanken darum machen, ob man das nicht ändern könnte. Meines Wissens laufen diese Debat seit etwa 20 Jahren.
Man muss ja ermutigt werden, politiker zu werden, oder?
Man hat immer wieder diese Diskussion darum, ob man nicht mehr Spitzenkräfte in der Politik brauchen würde. So Leute wie zum Beispiel den Werner Müller, der eine Zeit lang Wirtschaftsminister war, parteilos damals. Ich glaube, der kam von der... woher kam er?
Energie oder so.
Ich möchte jetzt auch gar keinen Namen nennen. Er kam aus dem Energiesektor auf jeden Fall. Und war dann unter der Schröder-Regierung zwei, war er dann Wirtschaftsminister. Oder war es eins? Ach.
Ja, der war so angenehm fahrblos.
Er war angenehm fahrlos.
Also er war so unpolitikerhaft.
Ja, er war unpolitikerhaft, sagen wir es mal so. Ob er eine gute oder eine schlechte Politik gemacht hat, sei mal dahingestellt. Das ist natürlich auch jedermanns eigenes Urteil. Aber natürlich ist es ungewöhnlich, denn als Abgeordneter hat er mit ziemlicher Sicherheit eine ganze Menge weniger auf dem Gehaltszettel gehabt als vorher als Vorstand eines großen Energieunternehmens.
Aber als Vorstand eines großen Energieunternehmens hat er zumindest so viel vorher auf dem Gehaltszettel gehabt, dass er sich nicht wirklich über so eine Pause viel Gedanken machen muss. Es sei denn, man kann nicht genug bekommen, oder?
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, wenn ich mich nicht ganz irre, ist er danach auch in einen nicht wesentlich weniger lukrativen Wirtschaftsbereich zurückgewechselt.
Ja, das, ah ja, natürlich. Klar, ich meine, wenn man mal Minister war, dann wird man danach meistens Berater.
Man kann auch, es gibt manche, die machen das, es gibt manche, die werden das nicht. Ich glaube, das hängt auch sehr stark vom Ressort ab. Wenn du Entwicklungshilfe oder Entwicklungszusammenarbeitsminister bist, weiß ich nicht, wie gut deine Chancen sind, danach Vorstand bei BMW zu werden.
Aber alle anderen, die jetzt nicht gerade zufällig Vorstand eines großen Energieunternehmens sind, für die könnte man ja eigentlich sowas einführen wie so eine Art Elternzeit, dass man sozusagen eine Garantie hat, wieder seinen Job zu bekommen.
Ja, wie gesagt, diese Diskussion läuft schon etwas länger, sie ist auch sehr facettenreich.
Aber es gibt zumindest Leute, die sind der Meinung, man müsste sich doch mal ein bisschen um Nachwuchs kümmern, also für das politische System.
Um Nachwuchs für das politische System, um mehr Frauen im Bundestag, denn es ist eine männerdominierte Veranstaltung, um mehr Leute aus nicht-akademischen Zirkeln, was tatsächlich auch sehr sehr gering ist von einem Anteil her. Ich glaube, die Akademiker-Quote liegt bei über 80 Prozent, was enorm hoch ist. Ja, schon im Verhältnis zur Gesamtbevölkerung repräsentativ ist das auf gar keinen Fall.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, gute Ausbildung schadet ja nun auch grad nicht, wenn man Volksvertreter ist, oder?
Na gut, wir haben das schöne Beispiel eines Ex-Bundeskanzlers, der eine gute Ausbildung genossen hat. Allerdings erst sehr spät, Gerd Schröder. Er hat eigentlich erst mal nur Volksschulabschluss gemacht und hat dann später auf zweiten Bildungsweg sein Amitur gemacht, hat dann Jura studiert, ist dann Anwalt geworden, ist dann Ministerpräsident in Niedersachsen geworden und ist dann Bundeskanzler geworden.
Und was er heute macht...
Und gilt er ja auch als Akademiker. Ja, aber erst spät. Das ist auch ein sehr ungewöhnlicher Lebenslauf. Allein das schon. Auch wenn er Akademiker ist, auf dem zweiten Bildungsweg.
Okay, also wir brauchen mehr ungelernte Hilfsarbeiter auf Minister.
Sagen wir es so, es würde auf jeden Fall dem Ganzen sicherlich mehr Farbe geben.
Aha, ja bestimmt in den Diskussionen, ja.
Wobei ich damit nicht sagen möchte, dass nicht mancher der gelernten Akademiker durchaus auch in der Lage ist, den Diskussionen ein gewisses Maß an Farbe zu verleihen.
Gut, so ein bisschen Ermutigung in die Politik zu gehen, das ist auch hier unser Ansatz heute Abend.
Also auch für diejenigen, die nicht studiert haben.
Genau, auch für die, die nicht studiert haben, das dürfte den Großteil meiner Hörerschaft ausmachen.
Oder auch diejenigen, die noch studieren. Es gibt zum Beispiel einige Abgeordnete.
Die haben alle studiert, aber die haben alle abgebrochen.
Ist egal, es gibt einige Abgeordnete. Ein schönes Beispiel dafür ist Nils Annen von der SPD in Hamburg. Der ist immer noch am Studieren. Ich glaube, das dauert auch noch.
Wie alt ist denn der?
Ich glaube, jetzt ist er knapp 30.
Na, mit 30 noch zu studieren ist ja kein Verbrechen, oder?
Ich glaube, er sitzt jetzt aber auch schon seit ein paar Jahren im Bundestag. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie viel Zeit er momentan darauf aufwendet.
Na, das ist ja eigentlich ein ganz gutes Zeichen, weil das lenkt ja bestimmt enorm ab, wenn man sich mal ein bisschen einbringt. Da kommen wir gleich zu. Aber bevor wir da mal ins Praktische gehen und mal so ein bisschen auch beleuchten, was Bundestagsabgeordnete eigentlich so treiben, oder auch Landtagsabgeordnete, wäre es vielleicht nochmal ganz interessant, ein bisschen auf das Gebilde als solches, über das wir reden, zu kommen. Wir haben ja schon erwähnt, wir wohnen in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. So, dem Staat. Was ist denn eigentlich ein Staat?
Also der klassische Jurist würde sagen, ein Staat ist nach Jellinek-Stadt drei Elemente leere. Ist ein Staat dadurch definiert, dass er ein Staatsgebiet hat. Das lässt sich relativ einfach umreißen bei der Bundesrepublik. Dass er ein Staatsvolk hat. Das ist auch relativ einfach zu definieren. Menschen, die auf diesem Territorium leben, da gibt es aber noch gewisse Einschränkungen. Und dass es die Staatsgewalt gibt. Die Staatsgewalt als solche ist die vom Staatsvolk oder in anderer Form übertragene Macht an einen Potentaten, also an einen, der herrscht. Oder an eine Institution, die herrscht.
Ohne Herrscher kein Staat?
Ohne Herrschaft gibt es keinen Staat. Ohne Herrschaft ist kein Staat zu machen. Das ist die klassische juristische Definition, die mit einigen Erweiterungen, aber grundsätzlich bis heute, auch weiter so gehandhabt wird, auch im internationalen Recht.
Das heißt, wenn ich mir eine Insel, die noch keiner hat, Kapa, ich meine, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, aber theoretisch...
Gab es schon, gab es schon.
Ich habe immer wieder von solchen Sachen gehört, dass Leute so einen Staat gründen wollten. Dann hatten sie erst mal das Problem, dass sie ein Volk brauchten. Dann mussten sie dieses Volk irgendwie dazu kriegen, sich beherrschen zu lassen.
Ja, das geht alles noch. Es gibt einen wunderbaren Fall eines auch jetzt recht höher kompatiblen Gebildes. Das ist die Insel Sealand. Sealand ist in dem Sinne keine Insel, sondern Sealand ist eine alte Marineplattform, ich glaube aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg der britischen Marine. Sealand liegt ein paar Kilometer außerhalb oder ein paar Meilen außerhalb des eigentlichen britischen Hoheitsgebiets. Und irgendwann ist mir jemand auch die wunderbare Idee gekommen, wenn man das jetzt besetzen würde, diese verlassene Militärplattform, dann hätte man doch den idealen Staat gefunden, nämlich einen, in dem niemand anders regiert, auf den niemand einen Anspruch hat, und auf den man selber noch das Staatsvolk stellt. Da gibt es bis heute einige Leute, die da auf Server betreiben, insbesondere für gewisse Zwecke. Es ist halt etwas schwierig, da legislativ tätig zu sein oder exekutiv tätig zu sein, dass man da durchgreift, um Recht durchzusetzen. Die Diplomatenpässe von Sealand waren früher sehr berühmt, weil viele Leute gerne einen Diplomatenpass haben wollten. Und die Insel Sealand, das Königreich Sealand, wie es offiziell hieß, und halt auch nicht offiziell hieß, weil der Staat international nicht anerkannt wurde, hat gerne Diplomatenpässe gegen Bares ausgestellt. War ein ganz gutes Geschäft, aber wurde international nicht wirklich anerkannt. Das heißt, mit einem Diplomatenpass der Insel Sealand kam er nicht so besonders weit. Also in der Theorie wäre es so wie mit dem Fall Sealand. In der Praxis ist es aber eigentlich nicht so. Typisches Problem, wenn man als Staat gelten möchte, braucht man auch jemanden, der einen als Staat anerkennt.
Stimmt. Das Problem haben wir noch so einige Staaten.
Aktuell wäre da zum Beispiel der Fall Kosovo was ganz interessant ist, wer da gerade wen anerkennt oder nicht anerkennen möchte und so weiter. Das gibt es ja häufiger. Russland mit Süd-Ossizien und ähnlichen Dingen. Das ist einer dieser vielen Fälle, wo dann die Frage ist, hat das Gebilde Staatsqualität? China und Taiwan ist auch ein wunderbares Beispiel dafür. Taiwan ist nicht Mitglied der Vereinten Nationen. War aber früher. Taiwan ist nicht mehr Mitglied der Vereinten Nationen. Dafür ist es Rot-China oder Festland-China oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte. Das war historisch eine Zeit lang anders. Aber seitdem die Volksrepublik ein gewisses Interesse bei anderen Staaten hervorgerufen hat, anerkannt zu sein, seitdem gibt es mit Taiwan, eigentlich für fast keinen Staat dieser Welt, offizielle diplomatische Beziehungen, also sehr, sehr wenige. Was nicht heißt, dass man mit Taiwan keine wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen pflegen würde. Aber keine offizielle diplomatische.
Aber dabei ist ja nun Taiwan ganz unzweifelhaft eigentlich ein Staat.
Ja und nein und historisch sehr, sehr schwierig aufgrund der Geschichte Taiwans und des Flüchtens eines gewissen Generals Chiang Kai-Shek. Vor Mao, nach Taiwan, inklusive Anhang und Staatskasse und so weiter. Das ist alles historisch nicht ganz simpel. Und doch theoretisch ist Taiwan ein eigener Staat. Praktisch ist es so, dass man dort eine gewisse Dualismus-Lösung gefunden hat, die vielleicht nicht ewig halten wird. Die hat sich im Laufe der Historie gefunden.
Was die Staatengemeinschaft hat.
Die Staatengemeinschaft und die verschiedenen Akteure innerhalb der Staatengemeinschaft haben dort eine Lösung herbeigeführt, gefunden. Aber wir kennen alle dasselbe Rasseln Chinas hin und wieder mal mit einer neuen Mittelstreckenrakete oder ähnliches.
Aber nach der Staatsdefinition, die du vorhin angeführt hast, würde das ja eigentlich passen. Da gibt es eine herrschende Klasse, die ist ganz unzweifelhaft vorhanden. Die übt auch Macht aus.
Taiwan ist eine fast beispielhafte Demokratie momentan. In Taiwan wurde gerade gewählt. Die Kuomintang sind jetzt wieder stärkste Partei geworden. Der Vorsitzende der jetzt oppositionellen Partei ist daraufhin zurückgetreten, der ehemalige Ministerpräsident. Wunderbar, gar nicht so häufig auf diesem Planeten, dass man wirklich eine funktionierende Demokratie hat, wo gewählt wird und die Leute, die gewählt wurden, sich auch tatsächlich danach richten. Es soll Länder geben. Kenia zum Beispiel soll etwas schwieriger sein momentan, wo dann Wahlkreise mit 110% Wahlbeteiligung existierten.
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen, da sind wir doch gleich wieder bei Wahlcomputern als Thema. Das wollten wir ja heute eigentlich mal nicht übertreiben.
Obwohl aus Taiwan fast sehr viele Motherboards und Ähnliches kommen. Man sollte Taiwan wirklich stützen.
Ja, deswegen finde ich das so absurd, dass ausgerechnet Taiwan nicht anerkannt wird. Ich meine, stellen wir mal vor, die würden sich jetzt quer stellen und sagen, wenn ihr uns als Staat nicht gibt, dann lösen wir uns jetzt irgendwie in einem Gedankenwölkchen auf.
Okay, einen ganz kleinen Seiten hier muss ich dann doch noch machen. Es ist höchst interessant zu sehen, dass ganz viele der berühmten taiwanischen Firmen, ich weiß gar nicht, was die korrekte Form ist, dass diese Firmen ganz häufig Fabriken auf dem chinesischen Festland betreiben, in denen sie ihre Produkte fertigen.
In Shanghai dann auf der anderen Seite, weil es noch billiger ist.
Zum Beispiel, weil es noch billiger ist.
Deutlich billiger.
Und das ist schon höchst interessant zu sehen, wer damit, wem und was.
Also China ist sicherlich noch mal so einen ganz eigenen Podcast wert. Da blicken wir wahrscheinlich beide auch nicht ausreichend durch. Und noch ist Chaosradio Express noch nicht das Auslandsjournal der Podcast-Rofäre. Aber vielleicht kommt das ja auch noch. Kommen wir zurück zu Deutschland. Da gibt es ja noch genug Dinge, die man da verstehen muss, bevor wir uns so mit fernen Welten auseinandersetzen. Ja, also wir haben den Start. Jetzt stellen wir das einfach mal fest. Es gibt die Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Und jetzt fragen sich natürlich immer so alle, wer übt denn jetzt hier eigentlich die Geschäfte wirklich aus? Man hat dann halt so den Bundeskanzler wahrscheinlich als erstes oder die Bundeskanzlerin, was ja vorhin in Abrede gestellt ist, dass es sich um die Bundeskanzlerin handelt.
Ja, per Definition, also im Gesetz steht der Bundeskanzler. Das ist deine Amtsbezeichnung.
Naja, vielleicht kriegen sie das ja noch geändert. Ich glaube, da wird sich dann keiner gegen sträuben.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man unbedingt im Grundgesetz stehen haben möchte, das Bundeskanzler.
Naja, aber der oder die oder was auch immer. Das ist auch egal. Oder vielleicht ist es auch nicht egal, aber das wollen wir jetzt auch nicht eräutern. Was ich schon mal ganz lustig finde, ist, als höchste Position in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland wird ja der Bundespräsident geführt. Warum ist er denn eigentlich die Eins?
Formal ist das vollkommen korrekt.
Also ist er, wie sagt man so schön, der höchste Repräsentant.
Er ist der höchste Repräsentant.
Also wenn er irgendwie auf die Party gehen will, dann kann sich keiner dazwischen schummeln.
Wenn er sagt, er geht dahin, dann muss der Rest hinten anstehen. Genau.
Dann muss auch der oder die oder das Bundeskanzler als Zweiter in den Seil marschieren.
Wird erst als Zweiter begrüßt werden.
Oder als Dritter.
Vielleicht sogar als Dritter.
Oder als Dritte.
Vielleicht auch als Dritte, je nachdem. Die Dritten werden die Ersten sein. Wir wissen es nicht. Nein, Bundespräsident zu sein, ist formal das höchste Amt im deutschen Staate. Praktische Auswirkungen hat es allerdings relativ geringe. Es ist etwas, was man aus der deutschen Geschichte glaubt, lernen zu müssen. Nämlich die starke Stellung des Reichspräsidenten früher. War nicht unbedingt ein Geschenk. Die unrühmliche Geschichte rund um Paul von Hindenburg und die Ernennung von Adolf Hitler zum Reichskanzler und die danach erfolgte Vereinigung der beiden Ämter und so weiter ist nicht unbedingt ein sehr positives Beispiel gewesen, mit einem starken Präsidenten in Deutschland zu arbeiten. Hat man deswegen nach 1945 geändert? Die Väter und die Mutter des Grundgesetzes, um es ganz korrekt zu formulieren, es war nur eine Frau dabei, waren der Meinung, dass man das nicht nochmal so haben wollen würde. Und entsprechend ist die Stellung des Bundespräsidenten primär eine repräsentative. Will heißen, der Bundespräsident tut relativ wenig inhaltlich. Er darf dem Volk ins Gewissen reden, den Parlamentariern, den Abgeordneten, allen möglichen darf er ins Gewissen reden. Er hat das moralische Recht dazu. Und qua Amt kann er das natürlich auch tun. Praktisch ist es so, dass er keine Weisungsbefugnis gegenüber irgendwem hat. Er hat noch nicht mal das Recht, tatsächlich jemanden auf eigene Faust hin zu entlassen oder zu ernennen. Das darf er nicht.
Also könnte man eigentlich auf den Präsidenten auch komplett verzichten.
Man könnte darauf verzichten, aber der Bundespräsident hat wiederum ein paar Dinge, die ganz nett sind. Also das Amt des Bundespräsidenten ist zum Beispiel dann toll, wenn man viele Staatsbesuche hat und zu wenige Leute, dann kann man das ein bisschen abmildern, dadurch, dass man das einfach auf die verschiedenen Positionen verteilt und sagt, der Bundespräsident ist formal das höchste Amt, der kann einen empfangen, gleichzeitig kann Frau Merkel den nächsten empfangen und dann haben wir vielleicht noch den Bundestagspräsidenten, der kann dann vielleicht...
Der Bundestagspräsident ist ja Nummer zwei.
In der formalen Hierarchie ist er eigentlich der Nummer zwei.
Er hat aber eigentlich auch kaum was zu melden, aber er kann zumindest Parteien zu Strafen verdonnern, das wäre schon mal was.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt wieder... Also das ist dann schon sehr speziell bundestagstechnisch. Das hat was mit der Bundestagsselbstverwaltung zu tun und dem Amt des Bundestagspräsidenten als Chef der Verwaltung des Bundestages und als Herr der Geschäftsordnung des Bundestages und so weiter. Das sind so spezielle Amtsdinge, die er zu verwalten hat. Aber ganz kurz zum Bundespräsidenten. Eine Sache, die immer wieder gerne diskutiert wird, ist eine, die auch historisch sehr nett ist. Konrad Adenauer hatte mal überlegt, Bundespräsident zu werden. Er hat es da nicht gemacht.
Nachdem er Kanzler war?
Nachdem er Kanzler war, nachdem ihm nahegelegt wurde, so langsam wäre es auch gut mit Kanzler sein, wurde ihm nachgelegt, er sollte doch gefälligst Bundespräsident werden. Der Bundespräsident stellte dann fest, dies Erfeststellen in einem Rechtsgutachten ist tatsächlich per Verfassung sehr, sehr schwach in seiner Position. Dadurch gefiel ihm das nicht mehr. Aber das Interessante ist, dass der Bundespräsident ein formales Prüfungsrecht hat. Das ist etwas, was Horst Köhler als erster Präsident eigentlich relativ stark ausgenutzt. Er prüft formal, ob ein Gesetz korrekt zustande gekommen ist. Witzigerweise hat er es jetzt tatsächlich geschafft, im letzten Jahr einmal ein Gesetz zu erwischen, was formal nicht korrekt zustande gekommen war. Einfach deswegen, weil ein Gesetz gemacht wurde. Im Laufe dessen hat man dann diese Föderalismusreform gemacht mit der Entflechtung von Land und Bund. Und man hat einfach übersehen, dass es ein Bundesgesetz war, was neuerdings in Länderkompetenz fiel. Da darf er dann sagen, das ist formal nicht korrekt, das muss ich nicht ausfertigen, das muss ich nicht verkünden lassen, denn das ist sein eigentlicher Job noch. Er darf noch gucken, ob ein Gesetz formal korrekt zustande gekommen ist. Und wenn er sagt, das ist es nicht, dann kann man sich entweder vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht darum streiten oder man kann es dann auch akzeptieren als vielleicht hat er recht.
Aber er hat auch noch andere Kriterien, oder? Also er kann auch sagen, das verstößt gegen die Verfassung.
Den Verstoß gegen die Verfassung, das wäre ein inhaltliches Prüfungsrecht, das hat er nicht. Er hat ein rein formales. Er kann nur sagen, es ist nicht im Sinne der Verfassung zustande gekommen.
Ach so, ist das nicht dasselbe?
Das ist nicht dasselbe. Im Sinne der Verfassung zustande kommen heißt, der Bundestag beschließt etwas und gegebenenfalls muss es der Bundesrat abnicken. Wenn jetzt der Bundestag etwas beschließt und sagt, das muss der Bundesrat nicht abnicken, dann muss er das nicht ausfertigen.
Aber was war denn das andere, was er nicht angenommen hat? War das dieses Luftsicherheitsgesetz oder die Luftüberwachung?
Genau, es gab die Luftüberwachungsgeschichte, das Luftfahrtsicherheitsgesetz. Ich komme gerade nicht auf den ganz korrekten Namen, ist auch irrelevant. Und es gab den Fall des Gesetzes, na, wie hieß es, was war es, was im Bundesrat so unglaublich umstritten war zwischen Schönbohm und Wurwereit? War es das Ausländergesetz?
Gibt es nicht alle Gesetze zwischen Schönbohm und Wurwereit?
Stritt ich? Unterschiedlich stark und auch längst nicht alle. Aber es war ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür, wo sich dann sehr offensiv gestritten wurde, wo dann auch offiziell Peter Müller, der Ministerpräsident des Saarlandes hinterher, nach der Bundesratssitzung meinte, war das nicht ein schönes Theater? Und ich glaube, es war das Gesetz rund um den, rund um Arbeitserlaubnisse für Ausländer oder ähnliches. Es ging auf jeden Fall um Migration letzten Endes. Und da gab es dann sehr große Unterschiede, ob das jetzt formal korrekt zustande gekommen ist oder nicht. Das war eigentlich das berühmteste Beispiel dafür. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, was das war. Es ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen her.
Na gut, brauchen wir uns nicht so lange jetzt mit aufzuhalten. Auf jeden Fall wissen wir, er hat noch nicht so richtig viel zu sagen. Bundespräsident ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt etwas, was jeder von uns ohne Weiteres anstrebt.
Was man auch nicht unbedingt so einfach anstreben kann, fällt einem manchmal auf die Füße. Im Fall von Köhler hat man das ja schön gesehen. Da hatte man einige Kandidaten und einige haben auch abgewunken. Klaus Zöpfer zum Beispiel, der für viele ein Kompromisskandidat gewesen wäre, ist es nicht geworden. Ja und nein. Was heißt Quoten-Präsi? Man muss halt eine Mehrheit organisieren. Was im Fall des Bundespräsidenten extrem komplex ist. Ich würde am liebsten heute Abend darauf verzichten, wie die Bundesversammlung zusammengesetzt ist.
Genau, das machen wir. Darauf verzichten wir jetzt. Und kommen jetzt mal auf den eigentlichen Teil, auf den wir zu sprechen kommen wollten. Weil sehr viel aktiver ist natürlich die Regierung, die Gesetze beschließt und vor allem der Bundestag. Und was sind denn so für dich die Erstrebenswerten? Oder mal anders gefragt, was sind eigentlich die Orte innerhalb des Staatsgefüges, an denen nun wirklich Politik gemacht wird? Also wer ist tatsächlich für eine Änderung und für neue Entwicklung wirklich zuständig?
Es gibt zwei Ebenen. Die eine ist die Ministerialebene. Das sind die Leute, die innerhalb der Ministerien Gesetzesvorlagen entwerfen. Das ist die eine Ebene, auf der sehr viel praktisch gearbeitet wird, inhaltlich gearbeitet wird. Das geschieht aber nicht im luftklären Raum. Diese Gesetzesvorlagen laufen aber immer durchs Parlament. Im Parlament ist das, wo die inhaltliche Arbeit stattfinden muss und auch nur kann. Trotzdem kann es natürlich sein, dass ich als Referent, mal nicht wegen in irgendeinem Ministerium, einen total tollen Gesetzesentwurf mache, den meiner Ministerin oder meinem Minister mitgebe und das dann ins Parlament eingebracht wird.
Wie wird man Referent?
Wie wird man Referent? Das ist eine klassische Verwaltungslaufbahn.
Was ist jetzt Referent? Ist das ein Beruf?
Das ist halt eine Bezeichnung. Du kannst halt Mitarbeiter in einem Ministerium sein, auf einer gewissen Ebene. Es gibt diese klassische Struktur, dass du oben einen Minister hast, dann darunter zwei bis drei Staatssekretäre, einen parlamentarischen und zwei Beamtete. Und darunter hast du dann die verschiedenen Verwaltungsmitarbeiter. Das sind meistens Sachbearbeiter irgendwann mal gewesen, sind dann aufgerückt zum Ministerialdirigenten und wie diese ganzen schönen Titel heißen, Ministerialdirektoren. Und die arbeiten alle inhaltlich. Man kann im Internet sehr schöne Übersichten finden, also teilweise sogar mit Durchwahlen für die verschiedenen Mitarbeiter der Ministerien, meist aber zumindest mit den E-Mail-Adressen, wer für was zuständig ist. Dann hat man das Organigramm vor Augen, dann hat man oben den Minister, danach diese Aufspitterung in die verschiedenen Abteilungen und da hat man dann die verschiedenen Zuständigkeitsbereiche. Ganz klassisch. Und die entsprechenden Leute, die dort sitzen, arbeiten inhaltlich an Themen.
Okay, was war das mit diesen beiden Staatssekretären? Also es gibt parlamentarische Staatssekretäre?
Es gibt parlamentarische Staatssekretäre und es gibt verbeamtete Staatssekretäre.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen denen?
Der Unterschied ist, dass ein parlamentarischer Staatssekretär, wie der Name es schon sagt, aus dem Parlament kommt. Der parlamentarische Staatssekretär ist sozusagen eine Stellvertreter des Ministers. Während die verbeamteten Staatssekretäre im Regelfall aus der Verwaltung selbst kommen.
Verstehe, also sind die, die sozusagen den Apparat kennen und da auch bleiben. Und die anderen sind sozusagen die politisch, die mit sozusagen zum politischen Willen beitragen.
Wobei im Regelfall, wenn ein Regierungswechsel stattfindet oder ein Ministeriums-Spitzenwechsel stattfindet, dadurch, dass eine andere Partei es übernimmt, alle Staatssekretäre ausgetauscht werden und häufig auch noch Referatsleiter.
Die Referatsleiter kommen dann direkt unter den Staatssekretären sozusagen.
Genau, da kommen die Referate, dann die Abteilungen.
Und die Referate sind auch die, die die Referenten stellen? Ja, jetzt macht das aber immer alles Sinn. Das heißt, Referenten sind Leute, die in einem Referat eines Ministeriums arbeiten. Und das sind sozusagen diejenigen, die an Gesetzesvorlagen dann auch als erste tatsächlich Hand anlegen in der Regel?
Es muss nicht unbedingt als erstes sein. Aber im Wesentlichen? Viele Gesetzesinitiativen kommen aus den Ministerien. Und zwar deswegen, weil irgendwo eine Notwendigkeit erkannt wurde oder zum Beispiel deswegen, weil es einen Urteil gibt von irgendeinem Gericht, wo zum Beispiel Definitionslöcken festgestellt wurden. Dass ein Gesetz zu unscharf ist und dort nachgebessert werden muss.
Oder gegen den Verfassungsverstößt oder was auch immer.
Auch das soll gegebenenfalls vorkommen. Dann müsste man halt ein neues Gesetz entwerfen oder ein Änderungsgesetz. Oder es kommt zum Beispiel von einer anderen politischen Ebene etwas. Zum Beispiel aus Brüssel. Kann ja durchaus auch mal eine EU-Richtlinie kommen, die dann in deutsches Recht umgesetzt werden muss. Das ist dann wieder Aufgabe innerhalb der Ministerien, dann entsprechend vorzuarbeiten. Ein Gesetz muss aber nicht aus dem Ministerium kommen. Er kann auch genauso gut aus dem Bundestag selbst kommen, also von den Abgeordneten. Da gibt es dann Vorschläge, Gesetzesvorlagen, die dann dort durchgearbeitet werden. Interessant ist eigentlich ein anderer Punkt. Dass diese ganzen Dinge grundsätzlich immer durch die Ausschüsse gehen. Die Ausschüsse sind sozusagen der Kopf des Bundestages. Man unterschätzt das immer so ein bisschen dadurch, dass man gerne auf das Herz guckt, nämlich auf den Plenarsaal, und sich dann immer fragt, wo sind die denn alle? Denn man hat abgesehen von der Haushaltsdebatte usw., hat man ganz häufig leere Ränge dort. Hat einen ganz einfachen Grund. Die sind nicht alle Kaffeetrinken. Manche sind sicherlich auch Kaffeetrinken. Sind auch nicht alle an der Bar. Manche sind vielleicht auch an der Bar. Es soll vorkommen, manche sind vielleicht sogar im Wahlkreis krank oder bereits gestorben, kommt auch vor. Die meisten sitzen dann gerade in ihren Ausschusssitzungen. So eine typische Parlamentarierwoche beginnt, klar, Montagmorgen, was ein Zufall, hat dann solche Dinge inklusive wie halt die verschiedenen Gremien. Das sind die Arbeitsgemeinschaften innerhalb der Fraktionen. Das sind die Sitzungen der Fraktionen. Das sind die Ausschusssitzungen, die verschiedenen. Das bestimmt in erster Linie den Kalender in der ersten Hälfte. Dann in der zweiten Hälfte der Woche eine Sitzungswoche. Es gibt Sitzungs- und Sitzungsfreier Wochen. In der zweiten Hälfte finden in erster Linie parlamentarische Debatten statt. Aber es ist nicht immer so, dass keine Ausschusssitzungen stattfinden würden. Aber meist weniger.
Die Arbeitswoche im Bundestag ist tatsächlich so aufgeteilt, dass man am Anfang ein bisschen sitzt.
Immer noch sitzt.
Aber am Anfang treffen sich mehr die Fraktionen und die Ausschüsse.
Das ist das normale, weil man am Anfang bespricht, wenn man taktisch vorgehen möchte, was ein Zufall. Dann muss man erst intern klären, wie man vorgehen möchte. Das würde andersherum wenig Sinn ergeben. Die Abstimmungen sind im Regelfall Mittwochs bis Freitags. Am Ende der Woche wird dann abgestimmt. Das darf man nicht falsch verstehen. Es ist nicht so, dass montags die Gesetzesvorlage in der AG diskutiert wird, dienstags in der Fraktion, dienstagsnachmittags im Ausschuss und am Freitagabend ist es im Parlament abgenickt. Ganz so schnell geht es dann doch nicht. Das sind meist Prozesse, die über mehrere Monate hinweggehen, teilweise auch über Jahre.
Wir wollen ja gerade jetzt auf die Strukturen, die Arbeit des Bundestages ein bisschen detaillierter eingehen. Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz ausholen und das sozusagen an seiner Entstehungsgeschichte festmachen. Wie setzt sich der Bundestag tatsächlich zusammen? Also was? Puh, wie setzt er sich zusammen? Da sitzen Abgeordnete, so viel ist glaube ich klar. Und in der Regel gehört ein Abgeordneter auch einer Fraktion an.
Im Regelfall gehört er einer Fraktion an und im Regelfall ist er auch Parteimitglied.
Aber man muss nicht in einer Partei sein, um Bundestagsabgeordneter zu werden.
Nein, man muss nicht in einer Partei sein. Man hat zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, sich direkt wählen zu lassen.
Wenn man total populär ist.
Wenn man total populär ist. Es gibt auch zum Beispiel Leute, bei denen es, sagen wir mal, eher sekundärer Wichtigkeit ist, dass sie in einer Partei sind. Das sind von den Abgeordneten zum Beispiel ein Hans-Christian Ströbele. Da könnte man jetzt darüber diskutieren, wie wichtig das grüne Label für ihn ist. Vielleicht ist es noch relativ wichtig, aber er schafft es zumindest, sich einen Direktmann dazu zu holen, was für die Grünen mindestens untypisch ist, allerdings auch viel mit seinem Wahlkreis zu tun hat.
Okay, aber er ist ja grüner. Er ist ja in einer Partei.
Genau, er ist auch in einer Partei. Aber es gibt immer wieder Fälle, es ist ungewöhnlich, dass ein parteiloser in den Bundestag gewählt wird. Das ist eigentlich fast ausgeschlossen, hat einfach auch was mit der Frage zu tun, was soll man mit ihm dann dort anfangen?
Mir fällt gerade ein Beispiel ein, der Neskovitsch, der schon bei der SPD war und mittlerweile für die Linke im Innenausschuss tätig ist.
Flexibilität ist ja nicht ausgeschlossen.
Ihr könnt natürlich jetzt auch bei den Linken eintreten, aber ich glaube, er hätte keinen Bock mehr auf Parteien. So war das auf jeden Fall herauszuhören.
Wenn ich mich nicht ganz vertue, dann ist er auch nicht mehr im Direktmandat eingezogen, sondern trotzdem auf Parteiticket, oder?
Genau, er ist, glaube ich, über die Liste dann reingekommen. Wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Also wenn man so will, wie Ströbele ist, Ströbele ist sehr populär und der tritt hier in Kreuzberg-Friedrichshain in Berlin an und wurde halt gewählt. Das war ja der Fall, dass er irgendwie von der Liste geschubst wurde bei den Grünen und dann so einen total personalisierten Wahlkampf gestartet hat. Wer Berlin und Kreuzberg-Friedrichshain kennt, weiß, dass da also sehr viel mehr rebellisches Potenzial zusammenkommt als in den meisten anderen Stadtteilen anderer Städte in Deutschland. Und so hat das dann eben ganz gut geklappt. In dem Moment ist er halt da er direkt, also weil er sozusagen die meisten Stimmen eines Kreises auf sich vereinigt hat, hat er sozusagen sein Mandat sicher gehabt.
Genau. Das ist eigentlich ein recht einfaches Prinzip, nachdem das im Bundestag funktioniert. In seinen Detail ist es dann wieder etwas komplexer. Aber das Grundprinzip ist, es gibt immer zwei Abgeordnete. Der eine ist der direkt gewählte und der zweite ist der über die Liste gewählt. Die Gesamtsumme soll eigentlich theoretisch 599 sein. Wir sind jetzt bei 606 Abgeordneten. Das hat etwas mit Überhangmandaten und Besonderheiten im Wahlsystem zu tun. Aber prinzipiell ist es so, dass man immer diese Zweiteilung hat. Wir haben 290 Wahlkreise momentan in Deutschland. Es ist auch egal, ob es drei mehr oder weniger sind. Es sollen alle relativ gleich groß sein. Es soll die gleiche Anzahl an Menschen dort sein, die wählt, damit die Stimmen auch gleich viel wert sind. Das hat viel mit Wahlgerechtigkeit zu tun. Das darf innerhalb einer gewissen Breite schwanken. Ich glaube, es sind 10-15%, was schon relativ viel ist. Aber ansonsten muss ein Wahlkreis umdesigned werden. Ich habe einen Abgeordneten, der von diesen Leuten bestimmt wird. Das ist meine erste Stimme. Ich wähle zum Beispiel jetzt mal, hier könnte ich mal in Prenzlberg, könnte ich mal hier in Pritlove wählen. Mit meiner ersten Stimme. In der zweiten Stimme könnte ich mir überlegen, wenn ich ihn wirklich ganz sicher drin haben möchte, wie mache ich das denn? Vielleicht ist meine erste Stimme nicht ganz so erfolgsversprechend, weil sehr wenig andere Menschen Tim Pritlove wählen würden. Das ist vielleicht ein etwas zu pragmatisches Beispiel.
Wir hätten bei Ströbeln bleiben sollen.
Auf jeden Fall könnte es sein, dass man dann auf Nummer sicher gehen möchte und sagen möchte, wenn der Pritlove jetzt nicht direkt gewählt wird, wie kann ich das denn versuchen, dass er trotzdem reinkommt? Vielleicht ist er auch noch Mitglied in irgendeiner Partei, bei den Diskordiern. Dann gebe ich meine zweite Stimme, die ich einer Parteiliste gebe, die gebe ich dann vielleicht mal den Diskordiern. Wenn die Berliner Diskordier dann über einen gewissen Prozentsatz hinauskommen, nämlich über die fünf Prozent, dann habe ich vielleicht das große Glück, dass Tim Pritlove eben diese fünf Prozent anteilig an den Abgeordneten, dass er dazugehört zu diesen fünf Prozent, die dann anteilig an Abgeordneten gestellt werden dürfen durch die Diskordier.
Wir haben jetzt die Partei, die Legion des Dynamischen Diskord, die LDD. Für die trete ich jetzt an. Du wirst nicht direkt gewählt. Ich werde nicht direkt gewählt, weil ich irgendwie zwei Stimmen zu wenig bekommen habe, um mich hier gegen den Bundestagspräsidenten durchzusetzen in Prenzlauberg. Den ehemaligen. Genau. Das heißt, ich muss dann auf der Liste sein. Und diese Liste dieser Partei stellt die Partei selber auf. Das heißt, sie stimmt da mehr oder weniger demokratisch drüber ab. Aber wodurch wird definiert, wie viele von dieser Liste tatsächlich dann reinkommen?
Du hast ja eine gewisse Anzahl an Abgeordneten. Diese habe ich eben schon erwähnt. Das sind diese knapp 600 bzw. gerade gut 600.
Also die sollen es sein. Die Hälfte wird direkt bestimmt und der Rest wird auf die Liste verteilt.
In der Theorie zumindest kommt das so etwa hin.
Das heißt, man nimmt dann einfach das prozentuale Verhältnis der Parteien und dann kriegt eben jede Partei...
Ja und nein und nein und ja. Ist extrem komplex.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht das ganze Wahlrecht im Detail durchkneten, aber das ist sozusagen der Weg. Entweder man ist populär genug und man macht sein Direktmandat oder man braucht aber eine Partei.
Man braucht eine Partei und hat einen guten Listenplatz, also eine Partei, mit der man relativ sicher ist. Kann zu dem komischen Effekt führen der sogenannten Überhangmandats bzw. eben nicht. Du kannst zum Beispiel einen hervorragenden Listenplatz haben. Wenn alle Leute direkt gewählt wurden, kommst du trotzdem nicht rein. Also in einem Bundesland wie Nordrhein-Westfalen kann dir das einfach passieren, dass alle Leute direkt gewählt wurden.
Welche alle Leute?
Also zum Beispiel, dass du...
Also alle, die auf der Liste stehen?
Ja, dass du eine... Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Ja, die schon mal sowieso, aber die Listenplätze mal abgesehen davon. Dadurch, dass du jetzt Nordrhein-Westfalen zum Beispiel hast, als ein Bundesland, in dem eine Liste zum Beispiel die SPD ist und jetzt wählen plötzlich alle Leute mit ihrem Direkt, also in ihrem Wahlkreis selber, immer mehrheitlich SPD. Dann hast du eine gewisse Anzahl von Wahlkreisen innerhalb Nordrhein-Westfalen und du hast theoretisch einen Stimmenanteil an Zweitstimmen. Aber diese Direktmandate sind schon so viele, dass über die Liste keiner mehr reinkommt, weil diese Direktmandate fressen das alles schon auf. Da bleibt nichts mehr übrig. Die Liste ist halt theoretisch zweitrangig.
Okay, verstehe. Das heißt, eine Liste funktioniert eigentlich wirklich gerade dann gut, wenn man möglichst wenig Direktmandate stellt?
Ja, zum Beispiel für FDP und Grüne ist das eigentlich der Standardweg, Parlamentarier zu stellen. Da sind dann auch die Hackordnungen, also da wird zumindest sehr stark um die Liste gehackt. Gleichermaßen ist es auch in Bayern bei der SPD so. Bei Bayern in der SPD ist ein Listenplatz schlechter als 20. Da hat er, glaube ich, auch relativ schlechte Chancen einzuziehen, weil es sehr wenig Direktkandidaten gibt.
Wenn man also jetzt ein Bundestagsmandat ergattert hat, dann fährt man nur noch mit einem Porsche rum.
Genau, dann fährt man nur noch mit einem Porsche rum. Viele sagen dazu dann Fahrbereitschaft oder so was. Ich glaube, im Regelfall sind es keine Porsches. Dann ist alles super. Dann hast du auch nichts mehr zu tun. Dein Terminkalender ist leer, niemand will was von dir. Du nickst einmal im Jahr alles ab und gibst dann deinen Blankoscheck ab. Nein, leider nicht.
Du warst schon mal im Bundestag.
Ich war schon mal im Bundestag.
Aber du warst kein Abgeordneter.
Ich war kein Abgeordneter.
Also gab es auch keinen Porsche.
Es gab für mich leider keinen Porsche. Es gab für mich immerhin meinen Mitarbeiter-Ausweis.
Was hast du da gemacht?
Mitgearbeitet, genau. An genau solchen Dingen wie Vorbereitung von Sitzungen, Vorbereitung von Reden. Sehr viel Kontakt mit so etwas wie Wahlkreisen. Das darf man nie ganz vergessen. Sein Bundestagsbüro ist im Regelfall so aufgebaut.
Du warst Mitarbeiter eines Abgeordneten?
Ich war Mitarbeiter bei Abgeordneten. Das war ganz interessant, denn das ist so, dass man dort wirklich erstmal den Einblick bekommt, wie klein das auch alles ist. Wir haben zwar ein relativ großes, komplexes Gebäudesystem hier in Berlin, was sich dann Bundestag und Co. nennt. Das ist halt primär. Das, was die meisten Leute kennen, ist die Reichstagsgruppe. Darunter ist der Plenarsaal. Unten drunter ist eigentlich sehr wenig, wo direkt gearbeitet wird. Da sind die Fraktionssäle noch in dem Gebäude. Dann gibt es noch die Nachbargebäude. Das ist das Paul-Löbe-Haus, wo sehr viele Ausschüsse sitzen. Und auch einige Büros von Abgeordneten sind. Dann gibt es das Marie-Elisabeth-Lüders-Haus.
Auf der anderen Seite des Flusses?
Auf der anderen Seite des Flusses, wo aber auch primär die Bundestagsbibliothek mit drin ist. Was auch sehr wichtig ist, also in irgendeiner Form so etwas wie Wissen und der wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages als Zuträger, sozusagen, arbeitet. Dann gibt es noch das Jakob-Kaiser-Haus, das größte aller Häuser. Da sind die meisten der Abgeordneten, das ist, ich glaube, in vier Sektionen aufgeteilt und ist sechs Stockwerke hoch und geht quasi da die halbe Wilhelmstraße lang, bis man dann vorne an die Ecke unter den Linden kommt. Da sind nicht ganz, ein bisschen davor endet das. Dann gibt es noch mal unter den Linden 50 und unter den Linden 17 gibt es auch noch mal Abgeordnetenbüros. Macht sich dadurch bemerkbar, dass bei schlechtem Wetter die Abgeordneten aus UDL 17 und 50 meistens fehlen.
Und wie muss man sich das jetzt so vorstellen, also so im Bundestag zu sein? Also was kann man denn da jetzt eigentlich wirklich bewirken?
Also im Regelfall ist es so, dass man Zuständigkeiten vorher definiert hat. Das ist anfangs einer Legislaturperiode ist es so, dass es ein großes Hicka gibt. Wer geht in welchen Ausschuss? Wer macht welche inhaltliche Arbeit? Wer wird wo Berichterstatter? Wer wird wo Ausschussvorsitzender? Das hat sehr viel mit Macht, Mitarbeitern usw. zu tun. Wer wird parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer? Auch ein Job, der nicht zu verachten ist. Das sind die Leute, die zum Beispiel sagen, jetzt ist eine Abstimmung, kommt mal bitte alle her. Wenn der seinen Job nicht gut macht, gibt es auch Probleme.
Innerhalb der Fraktion?
Innerhalb der Fraktion bist du der parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der jeweiligen Fraktion, der sogenannte PGF. Aber als normaler Abgeordneter bist du Mitglied in einem Ausschuss, also reguläres Mitglied in einem Ausschuss, beispielsweise innen, außen. Die sind ganz grob, also nicht ganz identisch, wie die Ministerien aufgeteilt. Es gibt mehr Ausschüsse als Ministerien. Es gibt halt ein paar Spezialausschüsse, sowas wie Menschenrechte und Co. Aber primär gibt es halt diese Spiegel-Aufteilung. So ähnlich wie im Bundeskanzleramt, dort gibt es Spiegelreferate zu den Ministerien. Also für jedes Ministerium gibt es dort ein Referat. Und so ein bisschen ähnlich ist das im Bundestag auch, so ganz grob von der Aufteilung her. Das heißt, man hat einen Innenausschuss, der ja immer wieder sehr beliebt ist, insbesondere beim Chaosradio, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Ja, da wird ja eine Menge, da wird ja, glaube ich, auch wirklich eine Menge Politik auch konkret bewegt, oder?
Da wird auf jeden Fall eine Menge Politik konkret diskutiert.
Diskutiert?
Diskutiert. Ob sie dort konkret bewegt wird, ja, sicherlich auch. Also dort findet Politik zumindest statt. Und natürlich ist die Frage, ist Diskussion von Politik nicht schon Politik?
Das heißt, diese Ausschüsse, das ist eigentlich der Ort, wo es geschieht.
Das ist der Ort, wo ich sagen würde, da geschieht am allermeisten.
Da ist auch das Parlament am meisten am Palieren.
Da ist das Parlament nicht nur am meisten am Palieren, sondern es gibt auch noch die feine Unterscheidung in öffentliche und nichtöffentliche Ausschusssitzungen. Wie man sich denken kann, die nichtöffentliche Ausschusssitzungen sind diejenigen, bei denen am deutlichsten geredet wird.
Öffentlich heißt, jeder kann dahin kommen?
Öffentlich heißt, jeder kann dahin kommen.
Wie viele Ausschusssitzungen sind so öffentlich und wie viele sind nicht öffentlich?
Der absolute Großteil ist öffentlich.
Wodurch wird eine Ausschusssitzung nicht öffentlich?
Es gibt ein paar Dinge, bei denen...
So alle zwei Monate, jetzt müssen wir endlich mal was gebacken bekommen?
Nee, es gibt... Es sind häufiger thematisch spezifische... Zum Beispiel der Verteidigungsausschuss. Tagt relativ häufig nicht öffentlich. Das ist hier nicht besonders überraschend, denn wir kennen das Geheimnis CRE-Mawisen. Der Sicherheitsinstitution kann man irgendwie auch nachvollziehen, wenn man jetzt diskutiert, ob man jetzt gerne drei Leute mehr oder weniger nach Afghanistan schickt und sich da noch nicht so ganz sicher ist. Da möchte man das vielleicht nicht morgen in der Zeitung stehen haben, dass gerade darüber diskutiert wird, dass drei Leute mehr oder weniger nach Afghanistan geschickt werden sollen. Zumindest nicht mehr im wörtlichen Zitat. Das findet sich garantiert noch einer, der hinterher berichtet, aber rein theoretisch zumindest wäre es so.
Also wie viele Ausschüsse gibt es so? 10, 15, 20?
Es gibt sicherlich 15, also 15 haben wir schon fast Ministerien, also eher 20. Gut, nur mal so in einer großen Ortung den Kopf zu kriegen. Variiert auch je nach Wahlperiode und so weiter. Grundsätzlich gibt es mehr Ausschüsse.
Und jeder Abgeordneter sagt, dass du musst in einem sein oder ist in der Regel in einem oder darf nicht mehr?
Jeder Abgeordnete ist im Regelfall in mindestens einem. Das kann man sich auch ganz einfach vorstellen. Eine große Fraktion hat vielleicht mal 250 Mitglieder. So SPD, CDU oder CDU-CSU-Fraktion, um genau zu sein. Ja, aber klar, bei denen ist das Hauen und Stechen natürlich etwas anders, als bei einer kleinen Fraktion, die nur 50 Mitglieder hat. Da sind diese Doppelzuständigkeiten schon eher mal gegeben, dass du halt sowohl Mitglied im Innenausschuss bist und dann auch mal hingehst, als auch dann auch noch im Ausschuss für Kultur. Es gibt Ausschüsse, Unterausschüsse.
Heißt das, dass die Abgeordneten von kleinen Fraktionen mehr zu tun haben?
In der Theorie hieß sie das, ja.
Und in der Praxis?
In der Praxis heißt es, dass sie sich wahrscheinlich dann entsprechend managen müssen, ja.
Wie gut kann sich denn so ein Abgeordneter da überhaupt managen? Also was für Mittel stehen einem denn da zur Verfügung?
Ein Abgeordneter hat Personalmittel. Das heißt, er kann sich selber seine Angestellten suchen. Die meisten Abgeordneten haben einen Büroleiter oder eine Büroleiterin, eine wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin, häufig eine studentische Hilfskraft, Praktikanten sowieso immer mal wieder.
Also kostenloses?
Ich glaube die Großteil. Es gab mal eine ganz interessante Szene, als diese ganze Diskussion um Generation P, Generation Praktikum, aufkam und sich herausstellte, dass einige der SPD-Abgeordneten, die sehr stark dafür votierten, ihren Praktikanten nichts zahlten, die meisten aus der CDU-Fraktion, die dagegen waren, jedoch sehr gut ihren Praktikanten bezahlen. Das fand ich ganz interessant, ganz amüsant.
Die waren gegen eine Bezahlung von Praktikanten?
Nein, diejenigen in der SPD, also manche zumindest, die sehr laut dafür argumentiert haben, dass Praktikanten fair und gerecht behandelt werden, stellte sich heraus, dass sie ihre Praktikanten eben nicht bezahlen. Das war etwas bitter. Eine kleine historische Anekdote, passiert schon mal, war das Personalbudget wahrscheinlich schon leer. Das ist nicht sehr viel. Meistens gibt es dann noch ein oder zwei Mitarbeiter im Wahlkreis, häufig auch nicht vor der Stelle. Aber so ein Bundestagsabgeordneter hat ein begrenztes Personalbudget, ein sehr begrenztes Personalbudget, was ein bisschen mit seinen speziellen Ämtern zu tun hat. Wenn er jetzt Ausschussvorsitzender ist, dann hat er entsprechend noch Mitarbeiter für den Ausschuss. Aber grundsätzlich ist es so, dass die Anzahl an Mitarbeitern und damit auch an Manpower und auch an Knowledge in irgendeiner Form aktiv Wissen zu generieren, einfach sehr überschaubar ist. Das ist ein bisschen anders als zum Beispiel in den USA, wo so ein Kongressabgeordneter tatsächlich auch mal seine 10, 12 Leute haben kann.
Ja, aber im Land mit 300 Millionen Leuten. Aber ich meine, wir sind ja auch nicht gerade klein mit 80 Millionen.
Wir sind auch nicht gerade klein.
Für mich klingt das ein bisschen wenig.
Für mich klingt das auch wenig, ja. Aber gut, okay.
Und warum ist das so?
Weil wir tatsächlich dafür sehr, sehr... Also wir haben sehr, sehr viel, was bei den Ministerien passiert. Wir haben sehr starke Ministerien. Und relativ schwache Abgeordnete, einfach nur von der Personalstärke. Was auch was damit zu tun hat, dass die Ministerien grundsätzlich immer berichtspflichtig sind gegenüber den Ausschüssen. Das heißt, theoretisch könnte man über eine kleine Anfrage an ein Ministerium wieder die Ressourcen innerhalb eines Ministeriums mitbenutzen und ähnliches. Praktisch ist es so, dass das keine Zusammenarbeit ist, sondern auch durchaus mal gegeneinander läuft. Wer sich mal diese typischen Protokolle anguckt von Bundestagsgeschehnissen, also heute im Bundestag, da ist eine Flut an kleinen Anfragen an Ministerien und so weiter immer dabei oder eine kleine Anfrage an ein Minister, was de facto dann heißt, wir hätten da ganz gerne eine Antwort drauf. Man hat selber dafür jetzt nicht die Manpower, um das rauszufinden. Also fragt man kurz beim Ministerium nach, was dazu verpflichtet ist, die Wahrheit dazu zu sagen oder zu sagen, wir brauchen dafür auch vier Wochen, wollt ihr das wirklich? Gut, das ist halt die klassische Arbeit.
Aber gibt es da nicht Bedürfnisse, irgendwie die Ausschaltung der Bundestagsabgeordneten zu verbessern?
Die Duftflüsse sicherlich.
Ja, aber wer kann denn das beschließen?
Der Bundestag.
Na ja, das sollte auch dem Bundestag da nicht sehr schwer fallen.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man sagt, dass man plötzlich das Doppelte am Personalbudget braucht, weil man gerne doppelt so viele Mitarbeiter hätte. Du kannst dir die Schlagzeilen selber vorstellen, oder?
Na ja, gut, aber ich meine, das ist der Bundestag.
Ja, es ist nur der Bundestag.
Ja, aber ich habe wirklich so den Eindruck, also ich habe jetzt selber nicht so viel mit Bundestagsabgeordneten zu tun. Ab und zu schon. Wir laden ja auch mal Leute in den CCC ein und so. So, mal wieder festzustellen, dass die eigentlich doch relativ einen überforderten Eindruck machen, bei dem sich auseinandersetzen mit Themen, was natürlich auch einfach was mit Personen zu tun hat, weil wenn man irgendwie keine Mitarbeiter hat, wie soll man dem denn folgen? Weil man ist ja eigentlich als Bundestagsabgeordneter selber permanent in irgendetwas schon eingebunden, oder?
Das ist ganz sicher so. Vor allem die große Schwierigkeit ist, dass du häufig über Dinge mitentscheiden sollst oder Dinge entscheiden sollst, bei denen du dich auf andere verlassen musst. Die Regelung ist im Regelfall so, dass du einen Berichterstatter hast zu einem bestimmten Thema in deiner Fraktion oder innerhalb deiner Fraktion. Und das sind diese Sprecher? Das muss nicht identisch sein. Ein Berichterstatter ist immer für ein konkretes Gesetzesvorhaben. Beispielsweise, wenn jetzt die Kleintierzüchter-Regelung geändert wird, ist der Abgeordnete Pritlove vielleicht der Berichterstatter für die diskordische Fraktion. Das heißt, alle anderen verlassen sich darauf, dass der Herr Pritlove sich damit intensiv beschäftigt und auch schon zum richtigen Schluss kommen wird. Es gibt manchmal ein paar Themen, bei denen man sagt, die sind von so viel Bedeutung, dass sich doch wesentlich mehr Abgeordnete damit beschäftigen sollten. Aber im Regelfall ist es so, dass nicht nur ein Abgeordneter in einem Ausschuss sitzt. Also, die Kleintierzüchter-Fraktion weiß ich gerade nicht, in welchem Ausschuss sie verhandelt werden würde. Ist aber auch nicht so wahnsinnig relevant. Auf jeden Fall, dort würde jemand anderes auch mit drin sitzen und der würde schon vielleicht mitbekommen, wenn du ein bisschen Mist machst. Das heißt, es gibt da auch so ein System von checks and balances, wie gut das funktioniert oder nicht funktioniert. Da kann man ein bisschen darüber streiten. Aber man muss sich auf seine Kollegen verlassen können. Und wenn man das nicht kann, ist man verlassen, ja.
Gut, aber wie... Ich meine, so, jetzt klingt das ja alles ein bisschen... Ja, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau, aber... Ist das denn eigentlich ein erstrebenswerter Job?
Bundestagsabgeordneter?
Ja!
Kommt drauf an, was du als Auswahl hast.
Was hat man denn so zur Auswahl?
Na ja, ich meine, jetzt wie unbedingt als Auswahl als Bundestagsabgeordneter, ich glaube nicht, dass das so ein wahnsinnig erstrebenswerter Job ist. Denn zumindest wenn du ihn ernst nimmst, ist er sicherlich nicht erstrebenswert. Denn dann wirst du einen relativ langen Arbeitstag haben. Du wirst sehr, sehr viel unterwegs sein. Du wirst vielleicht auch relativ viel von der Welt sehen können. Das kann dir auch passieren. Aber du wirst eine Menge Probleme und wenig Dank ernten. Da bin ich mir recht sicher. Also wenn du als Abgeordneter deine Tagespost aufmachen lässt, du machst die im Regelfall nicht selber auf, weil du das gar nicht bewältigen könntest, Abgeordnete bekommen im Regelfall mehrere Dutzend persönliche Briefe jede Woche. Und da soll dann eine möglichst persönliche Antwort darauf erfolgen. Das sind teilweise herzzerreißende Geschichten. Und wenn du ein guter Abgeordneter bist, dann kümmerst du dich darum, dass der Richtige sich darum kümmert. Häufig sind es einfach nur Menschen, die verzweifelt sind und sich dann nicht mehr zu helfen wissen und an ihren Abgeordneten schreiben. Es gibt einen öffentlich dokumentierten Fall von jemandem, der seine persönliche Kriegserklärung an den Bundestag geschickt hat, und zwar nicht an irgendwen, sondern an alle Abgeordneten, in 3-Punkt-Schrift hinten drauf gedruckt. Alle Empfänger, das betraf alle Bundes- und Landesbehörden, Landesverfassungsschutzämter, Abgeordneten usw. Der Mensch muss an Schweinegeld für Porto ausgegeben haben, hat aber damit richtig schön gespammt. Und das wirklich in Briefform. Das heißt, es ging per Post als vielseitiges Schreiben bei allen ein. Kriegserklärung? Seine persönliche Kriegserklärung an die Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Ich weiß nicht, was aus ihm geworden ist. Ich glaube, es hatte keiner angenommen.
Gut, aber ich meine, das klingt jetzt alles so ein bisschen, das klingt so ein bisschen, ja, ach Gott, langweiliger Job, viel zu tun, ist ja alles furchtbar. Aber wir beklagen ja eigentlich immer so ein bisschen so dieses, naja, alle reden von Politik, aber keiner macht es. Konkrete Mitarbeit im politischen Geschehen wird dann meist auch unter dem Ich-muss-jetzt-Lobbyist-werden abgebucht. Was ist denn so deiner Meinung nach eigentlich ein gängiger Weg, um wirklich effektiven Einfluss auf das politische System zu nehmen? Ich bin jung und ich habe tolle Vorstellungen und Ideale oder was auch immer. Oder vielleicht bin ich auch einfach kundig genug in zwei, drei Themen und habe einfach ordentliche Sachkenntnis und möchte jetzt gerne was einbringen. Vor allem möchte ich gerne verhindern, dass so Sachen wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung überhaupt in Form einer Gesetzesvorlage entstehen. Was kann man tun? Wo greift man da ein?
Du hast natürlich sehr, sehr viele Möglichkeiten. Die Anzahl an Möglichkeiten ist natürlich nahezu unbegrenzt. Aber du hast nach den Effizienteren gefragt. Ich glaube nicht, dass es wahnsinnig effizient wäre, dafür eine parlamentarische Karriere anzustreben, das was du gerade gesagt hast. Eine parlamentarische Karriere bedarf langer Vorbereitungszeit, bedarf hohen Engagements. Natürlich gibt es Wahlkreise, die sind einfacher, und es gibt Wahlkreise, die sind schwerer zu gewinnen. Prinzipiell ist es so, dass du aber damit eine Menge Arbeit haben wirst und nicht mit einem... Du kannst dich einfach anklopfen und sagen, hallo, ich will hier rein. Die meisten Parlamentarier haben diese sogenannte Oxentour gemacht. Das heißt, sie waren vielleicht mal Mitglied in einer Jugendorganisation einer Partei, haben dort schon gezeigt, dass sie in einer Organisation klarkommen, dort auch mit Menschen Verhandlungsprozesse durchführen können. Manche nennen das Ausleseprinzip, andere sagen, selbstselektieren das System dazu. Da kann man auch darüber streiten, wie sinnvoll das ist oder nicht sinnvoll das ist. Es gibt aber wenig Politiker, die Stand-Up-Politiker geworden sind, die aus dem Nichts kamen und plötzlich da waren. Das ist natürlich etwas, wo sich auch die wenigsten Leute darauf einlassen wollen, dass sie jahrelang daran arbeiten, dass sie irgendwann an diesem Punkt sind, dass sie diesen Posten haben, an dem sie Einfluss ausüben können. Ich halte es für deutlich effizienter, zumindest wenn es sich um etwas eher kurzfristigeres handelt, sich tatsächlich extern durch Druck politisch zu betätigen. Druck ist jetzt noch gar nicht negativ gemeint, sondern Druck ist Aufmerksamkeit. Jede Form von Aufmerksamkeit für bestimmte Themen landet letzten Endes auch bei Politikern. Die Frage ist, wie erzeugt man Aufmerksamkeit, und zwar auch so, dass sie ankommt. Natürlich kann man es machen, dass man seinem Abgeordneten wie häufig den vorgefertigten Ausdruck von Verdi unterschreibt und per Post zuschickt. Das finde ich relativ nett. Darauf gibt es dann ein genauso formalisiertes Antwortschreiben vom zuständigen Berichterstatter der jeweiligen Fraktion, der seine drei Textbausteine zusammenklickt und sagt, gut, sie haben uns diesen wunderbaren Brief geschickt, also schicken wir ihnen genau diesen Formbrief zurück. Das ist auf gut Deutsch Blödsinn. Kostet nur Arbeitszeit, vernichtet nur Arbeitszeit. Okay, gehört aber offenbar auch dazu. Das halte ich für nicht so besonders sinnvoll. Was ich für sehr viel sinnvoller halte, ist tatsächlich die Abgeordneten zu besuchen. Die Abgeordneten haben fast alle Bürgersprechstunden in ihrem Wahlkreis. Und es gibt wenig, was so gut passt, wie Interesse zu zeigen, indem man tatsächlich zu den Leuten hingeht und sich ihnen gegenüber setzt und sagt, schönen guten Tag Herr oder Frau XY, ich habe ein politisches Anliegen. Ich möchte, dass sie sich damit beschäftigen, denn das ist wichtig. Ich möchte, dass sie nicht total ignorant gegenüber diesem Thema sind, weil es vielleicht nicht ihr eigenes ist. Aber ich möchte ihnen sagen, hier und dort liegt meiner Meinung nach das Problem.
Hast du schon mal gemacht?
Ich habe das auch schon mal gemacht, natürlich.
Was ist das für ein Thema?
Das sage ich nicht.
War wohl etwas ganz Verfängliches.
Das war etwas ganz Verfängliches, natürlich.
Aber du hast eine Reaktion bekommen.
Natürlich habe ich eine Reaktion bekommen, denn die Person saß mir gegenüber.
Wie war die Reaktion? Oh, endlich besucht mich mal jemand.
Nicht ganz, nicht ganz. Darüber können Sie jetzt noch nicht unbedingt.
Ist da eine Menge los?
Es kommt immer darauf an, wie populär der jeweilige ist. Denn je populärer der Kandidat, umso mehr Omas wollen mit ihm gerne auch Kaffee trinken.
Echt? Die kommen da vorbei und wollen Unterschriften haben?
Naja, das ist wie im typischen Arztwartezimmer, was sowas angeht.
Wie im Arztwartezimmer warten Unterschriften geiler?
Herr MDB, sprechen Sie mit mir. So ein bisschen. Nicht Unterschriften sammeln, sondern eher...
Gruppis, Fans, Leute, die sich Gehör verschaffen wollen.
In die Richtung. Und die Durchschnittstrolle, die wir auch alle kennen.
Okay, aber jeder Abgeordnete zählt ja eins, von daher ist ja egal. Aber man sollte eigentlich schon in seinen eigenen Wahlkreis?
Entweder nach Wahlkreis gehen oder... Das ist das, was rein logistisch am einfachsten ist, dass man erst mal zu seinem Wahlkreisabgeordneten geht. Der ist nun mal im Wahlkreis vor Ort. Im Regelfall jede zweite bis dritte Woche wird er eine Bürgersprechstunde anbieten. Oder vielleicht auch einmal im Monat, da kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was für ein Amt er genau hat. Aber grundsätzlich sind diese Menschen verfügbar. Man kann sich mit ihnen treffen. Man sollte aber auch nicht mit Schaum vor dem Moment hinkommen, weil das gibt wenig Sinn. Das bringt nichts. Dann reden die Menschen halt auch nicht mit einem. Das wüsste ich wirklich, sie hören einem vielleicht noch zu, aber sagen dann Tschüss, schönen Tag noch. Schön, dass sie da waren. Es sind ja meistens auch etwas, sagen wir mal, in politischer Kommunikation ausgebildete Menschen, also zumindest gebildete Menschen, die sich auch nicht so schnell aus der Reserve locken lassen. Was aber jetzt nicht heißt, dass man dort mit einer Mauer reden würde oder mit einem Pudding, ist es auf jeden Fall gut, eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit dafür zu erzeugen, dass dort Menschen sind, die tatsächlich mit ihrem Gesicht dafür stehen, dass sie ein Thema wichtig finden. Und das ist das, was glaube ich relativ gut funktioniert. Wenn man das in ausreichender Zahl macht, dann sorgt das tatsächlich auch für sowas wie, naja, dass der Abgeordnete vielleicht dann mal sagt, oder die Abgeordnete dann mal sagt, ja, bei mir laufen neuerdings so viele Leute in der Sprechstunde auf, die haben alle irgendwas mit diesem komischen Thema. Das macht doch der Kollege XY. Können Sie mir dazu mal ein paar Sachen raussuchen? Gut, und dann sucht man vielleicht ein paar Sachen dazu raus, und dann wird er sich vielleicht tatsächlich inhaltlich damit mehr beschäftigen, als er es sonst gemacht hätte.
Okay, aber ist das jetzt schon die einzige Möglichkeit? Weil da ist man ja dann immer noch davon abhängig, dass der Abgeordnete, man kann auch sagen, dass er dir dann irgendwie zuhört und sagt, schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Jetzt muss ich aber wieder zu meinen Lobbyistenfreunden auf die Party, weil da gibt es in zwei Stunden ordentlich Essen.
Ja, das kann natürlich passieren, halte ich aber nicht für den Regelfall. Das ist natürlich nicht die einzige Möglichkeit. Natürlich kannst du auch versuchen, klassisch dadurch Einfluss zu nehmen, dass du sagst, dass du zum Beispiel Leute kontaktierst, die in gewissen Ausschüssen sitzen, die relevant sind. Einfach Ausschüsse, die relevant sind für ein Gesetzesvorhaben, was dich persönlich interessiert. Wenn du dann versuchst, Kontakt aufzunehmen, klar. Da gibt es dann verschiedene Mittel und Wege. Der Regelfall ist, je nachdem, was für eine Person du bist. Wenn du jetzt eine Person bist, die einen gewissen Background hat und in dem Bereich vielleicht prominent ist, oder zumindest bekannt bist oder bei einer Firma arbeitest, die bekannt ist oder so. Sobald du in etwas exponierterer Stellung bist, dann würde ich natürlich mal versuchen, mich mit diesen Abgeordneten oder einigen dieser Abgeordneten auf den Kaffee zu treffen. Na klar, warum denn nicht? Dann kannst du dir noch sagen, sie dürfen ihren Kaffee auch selber bezahlen, damit sie sich nicht als bestechlich empfinden.
Aber jetzt hast du gerade einen interessanten Punkt aufgebracht. Den finde ich gerade insofern jetzt auch nochmal beleuchtenswert, weil das ja gerade eine große Rolle spielt. Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist jetzt Anfang dieses Jahres offiziell erstmal in Kraft getreten, inwieweit sie jetzt wirklich schon einen konkreten Auswirkungen hat, das sei mal dahingestellt. Und es gab in den letzten Monaten extrem viel Aktivismus dagegen. Es gab Demonstrationen, Pipapo. Das Problem ist allerdings, dass dieser ganze Aktivismus eigentlich erst zu einem Zeitpunkt begonnen hat, wo das Ding eigentlich schon komplett aus allen Ausschüssen raus war. Eine konkrete Gesetzesvorlage war, und die Bundestag nur noch darauf gewartet hat, dass der Tag kommt, wo sie dann endlich mal darüber abstimmen können. Wie weiß man denn eigentlich, dass ein Gesetz in Vorbereitung ist? An welcher Stelle muss ich mich jetzt eigentlich einklinken, um auch wirklich so ein Frühwarnsystem aktivieren zu können?
Also ich würde sagen im RSS-Feed von bundestag.de und zwar in dem Bereich, wo die Themen der Ausschüsse behandelt werden, nämlich heute im Bundestag. Heute im Bundestag umfasst nicht nur die Sachen, die im Bundestagsplenarsaal stattfinden, sondern auch tatsächlich die Ausschuss-Themen. Das ist der Bereich, wo du spätestens tatsächlich dann die Sachen findest, wenn sie auf der Agenda stehen. Ein Gesetz, das durch den Bundestag geht, hat eine erste, eine zweite und eine dritte Lesung. Erst mit der dritten Lesung wird es verabschiedet. Zweite und dritte werden manchmal zusammengefasst, aber zumindest zwischen erster und zweiter hast du noch eine Möglichkeit, Änderungsanträge und so weiter einzubringen, es auch wieder verwerfen zu lassen und so weiter. Aber eigentlich hast du es vorher schon mal im Ausschuss. Im Regelfall geht es erst in den Ausschuss oder es wird nach der ersten Lesung in einen Ausschuss verwiesen. Also an die zuständigen Ausschüsse.
Also erste Lesung heißt, dass da aber schon ein Gesetzentwurf konkret vorliegt. Und geht dem Gesetzentwurf als solches noch irgendetwas voraus?
Meistens geht dem Gesetzentwurf, der überhaupt nicht zur ersten Lesung kommt, gehen schon diverse Vorenwürfe voraus. Zum Beispiel Referentenentwürfe in Ministerien, von denen wir schon gesprochen hatten. Manchmal auch Anträge auf Gesetzesvorlagen innerhalb von Fraktionen oder aus Fraktionen heraus.
Das heißt, dieser RSS-Feed, den du jetzt angesprochen hast, muss ich mir jetzt mal klicken hier. Weißt du, wo der liegt?
Bup, irgendwo unter bundestag.de findest du gleich. Der ist relativ prominent, die haben eine relativ gute Seite.
Irgendwo unter bundestag.de, das bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Und dann unter heute im Bundestag?
Heute im Bundestag.
Oder sogar heute in den Ausschüssen.
Experten kritisieren Pläne zur Reform der Bundespolizei. Geändertes Eigenmittel-System der EU. Deutsches Recht übernimmt...
Man hört schon, das klingt unglaublich spannend.
Aber ich sehe da kein RSS-Feed, um ehrlich zu sein.
Wenn du mal den Rechner drehst, dann kann ich mal ganz kurz schauen.
Da sind nur so...
Nur so...
Da sind nur so jetzt so vier Punkte zu drücken. Wir machen jetzt hier mal ganz konkrete Politik-Forschung. Wir machen ganz konkrete Politik-Forschung. Wir lesen uns eine Webseite durch.
Ja, genau.
Also es gibt hier natürlich schon einen RSS-Feed, aber der ist jetzt sozusagen für alles. Aber ich habe mir jetzt einen Experten an den Rechner geholt, der für mich das Internet ausdruckt. Das ist ja, wie man das im Bundestag auch macht. Das habe ich erst auf dem Kongress wieder gesehen, wo Markus Begdal seinen schönen Vortrag gehalten hat, 23 Dinge, die ich irgendwie tun kann. Da kam er das mit den Bundestagsabgeordneten auch zur Sprache. Und dann meldete sich dann der Taus, der dann ja irgendwie selber Abgeordneter ist, aber auch immer gerne am Kongress teilnimmt, der ja auch schon mal einen Vortrag gehalten hat von der SPD. Und dann meint er so, ja, ja, das stimmt schon, mit dem Internet ausdrucken und so. Also schicken sie uns lieber einen Brief. Ja, das ist...
Ganz ehrlich, das ist ökologisch auch nicht viel besser, denn besser wird es vor Ort ausgedruckt, als dass man das noch mal mit der Post befördern muss.
Ja, aber ein richtiger Brief scheint einfach eine ganz andere Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie zu machen. Also das mit diesem virtuellen, das ist irgendwie alles so.
Ja, und ich bin gerade offensichtlich auch nicht mehr in der Lage, den RSS-Dienst zu finden.
Hier sind die HEB-Meldungen des Deutschen Bundestages.
Ja, aber das sind die nicht... da ist nicht der RSS-Dienst.
Das gibt man dann per E-Mail.
Ah, rufen wir mal, ich bin zu doof. Oben rechts haben wir sie doch. RSS-Dienste. Unter Service, Aktuelles, RSS-Dienste. Was ist RSS? Analyse und Gutachten, HIV-Meldungen des Deutschen Bundestages, aktuelle Themen des Deutschen Bundestages und den Newsletter. Du kannst entweder die aktuellen Themen nehmen oder eigentlich die Meldungen heute im Bundestag. Die Analyse und Gutachten der Wissenschaftlichen Dienste sind insofern interessant, als dass sie den Common Sense, also zumindest den Common Ground, des Wissens für den durchschnittlichen Bundestagsmitarbeiter stellen. Denn wenn er was nicht weiß, guckt er im Zweifel erst mal beim Wissenschaftlichen Dienst nach.
Das heißt, da tauchen auch so Sachen auf wie Technikfolgenabschätzung und ähnliche Sachen?
Da tauchen einige Sachen auf, wie zum Beispiel das Thema Online-Durchsuchung ist irgendwann auch mal dort definiert worden, was eigentlich Online-Durchsuchung sein soll. Oder Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist wahrscheinlich auch mal.
Benutzt du denn auch so abgeordnetenwatch.de und ähnliche Websites, die sich da jetzt versuchen, da der breiten E-Demokratie...
Ja, es gibt ja sehr unterschiedliche Ansätze, was das Ganze angeht. abgeordnetenwatch.de halte ich tatsächlich für als der, sagen wir mal, vielversprechenderer. Da ist tatsächlich, wie will man sagen, es ist ein ganz einfaches Prinzip dahinter, nämlich ich stelle öffentlich eine Frage und ich erwarte öffentlich eine Antwort. Das Prinzip halte ich für nicht ungewöhnlich. Das ist so, als ob ich einen Anschlag auf den Marktplatz mache. Also nicht einen Anschlag, sondern einen Anschlag. Und dort einfach nur eine Frage stelle, wie zum Beispiel, was haben Sie letzte Woche getan? Also Herr Abgeordneter, was haben Sie letzte Woche für meinen Wahlkreis getan? Was haben Sie für meine Freiheit, meine Rechte, meine Sicherheit getan? Das ist eine Frage, die ist legitim zu stellen. Und wenn der Abgeordnete der Meinung ist, dass du darauf eine Antwort verdient hast, dann beantwortet er sie. Und wenn nicht, dann sieht jeder, dass er das nicht beantwortet hat. Ich sehe da noch kein Problem drin. Das finde ich eigentlich relativ in Ordnung. Es gibt auch genug Fragesteller, die sich bei derartigen Portalen selbst disqualifizieren, als dass man sieht, warum sie keine Antwort erhalten, muss man leider auch fairerweise sagen. Es gibt Themen, zu denen würde ich als Abgeordneter dann auch nicht antworten wollen. Aber ich glaube, Abgeordneten von watch.de zum Beispiel ist auch relativ gut moderiert, um solche Sachen zu filtern und auch gewisse Dinge rauszufiltern, die einfach nur die 370. Wiederholung der gleichen Frage sind. Das ist auch für jeden anderen irrelevant. Da kann man irgendwo noch mal ein MeToo-Button runterpacken. Aber das war's dann auch. Inhaltlich relevanter wird es dadurch dann doch nicht. Und die Antwort wird die gleiche bleiben. Und 370-mal auf die gleiche Frage, die gleiche Antwort. Das sind halt diese Standardbriefe, von denen ich schon sprach, die für die Gewerkschaften ganz berühmt sind und ähnliche Interessenverbände.
Okay, also das ist jetzt auch im Prinzip eine Empfehlung von dir. Also du würdest meinen, man sollte sich schon da über solche Portale, wie vor allem bundestag.de, einklinken, um sozusagen den politischen Prozess zu beobachten?
Man sollte den politischen Prozess auf jeden Fall auf solchen Wegen beobachten. Und wie sagt man das so schön? Es gibt ganz praktische Beispiele. Politik ist nicht unbedingt immer das große Ganze. Politik kann auch das kleine Feine sein. Es ist zum Beispiel ein ganz klassisches Problem. Der ganz kleine politische Akt ist zum Beispiel in der eigenen Gemeinde. Ich habe selber mal vor dem Problem gestanden, dass ich aus persönlichen Gründen und so weiter, dass ich mitbekommen habe, dass es eine Entscheidung geben sollte, die EDV der Kommune an einen externen Dienstleister auszulagern. Einen gemeindeeigenen, also nicht Gemeinde, sondern kreiseigenen, zusammen mit einem anderen Kreis. Das war schon geschehen. Genau so war es. Die Auslagerung hatte stattgefunden, und dieser Dienstleister sollte etwas umsetzen. Und stand damit in Konkurrenz zu anderen privaten Anbietern. Das Votum sah sehr stark danach aus, weil es ja quasi der gemeindeeigene, zumindest indirekt noch, dass man ihn doch auch nimmt dafür.
Aber dann kommt dann wahrscheinlich gleich wieder die Wettbewerbsvorschriften da bitter rein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Es war leider sehr bitter, denn ich habe dann sehr stark daran gearbeitet, durch Gespräche vor allem, sehr stark daran gearbeitet, dass das nicht geschieht. Denn ich hatte mir die Konzepte besorgt, um die es da im konkreten Fall ging. Und die Konzepte waren für mich der Gestalt, dass ich diesem Dienstleister leider jede Seriosität absprechen musste. Es war einfach sehr, sehr bitter, denn was er dort schrieb, war einfach Unfug. Es war einfach technisch Unfug. Und das ist einfach viel in der Sachverstand in dem Fall. Wenn selbst ich schon sagen kann, dass es technischer Unfug ist, das will schon einiges heißen. Und na gut, im Endeffekt ist dieser Dienstleister dann auch nicht geworden. Würde ich mir in dem Fall auch auf meine eigene Fahne schreiben, war ein kleiner politischer Akt im Lokalen, wo aber tatsächlich einfach nur fehlende Kompetenz ansonsten dazu geführt hätte, dass es verdammt teuer geworden wäre für alle. Und sich für das Lokale zu interessieren, dadurch kann man sich auch eine gewisse Reputation aufbauen. Wenn man sich eine gewisse Reputation aufbaut, kann man natürlich dann auch wieder Einfluss nehmen. Dann heißt es schon nicht mehr von wegen, was ist denn das für einer da, der Herr Pritlove da aus dem Prenzlberg?
Wie lokal war das jetzt?
Das war in dem Fall 16.000 Einwohner lokal.
Also ein Dorf?
Gemeinde. Wirklich Gemeinde eben.
Also war das jetzt so eine dörftliche Struktur, oder war das ein Stadtteil einer?
Das ist eine kleine Stadt. Aber halt mit sehr ländlicher Struktur. Also nicht sehr urban. Aber das unterscheidet auch nicht. Das ist genau das Gleiche, wenn man jetzt hier in eine Bezirksverortungsversammlung in Berlin geht oder vielleicht noch kleinere Ebenen. Wenn man mal tatsächlich zu einem Treffen von Parteien geht, als interessierter Bürger ist man im Regelfall willkommen. Man kann hingehen und sich mit den Themen beschäftigen. Man kann einfach mal Expertise einbringen. Vor allem, wenn man sieht, dass es diese Themen gibt. Und wie gesagt, inzwischen setzen immer mehr von diesen kleinen Parteigliederungen und so weiter, aber auch von Verwaltungsgliederungen, setzen immer mehr auch auf größere technische Systeme, auf die gewisse Standards anbieten, wie zum Beispiel RSS. Und mir fehlt da noch eine richtige Suchmaschine, für die solche Seiten natürlich sindiziert. Und wo man dann zielgerichtet sagen kann, ich interessiere mich nur für Berlin und nur für Linux von mir aus oder nur für Windows. Und ich möchte gern alles haben, was da dann stattfindet. Und dann gehe ich dann vielleicht auch hin. Das fehlt mir noch so ein bisschen, so ein Eventmanager sozusagen dafür.
Ja, ich überlege auch gerade, ob nicht vielleicht mal so eine kleine Web 2.0-Bude sich nicht mal das Heil in der Politikbeteiligung suchen sollte, dass man sozusagen ein System hat, in dem sozusagen sowas auch leichter getrackt wird.
Es gibt tatsächlich einige Versuche von irgendwelchen kleinen Web 2.0-Buden, naja, die, würde ich mal sagen, eher begrenzten Horizont haben, in dem was sie tun und treiben, und auch total interessante Refinanzierungsmedaille an den Tag gelegt haben. Sagen wir es anders, der ernsthafte Zugang dazu fehlt mir noch ein bisschen, auch wenn manche behaupten, sie würden dies sehr ernsthaft treiben. Ich sehe es einfach anders. Das mag vielleicht an meinem persönlichen Blick auf Politik und Web 2.0 und so weiter liegen.
Was ich eigentlich mehr meinte, ist so ein Issue-Tracking. Nochmal dieses konkrete Beispiel Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Was mir zumindest fehlt, vielleicht gibt es das ja, aber mir fehlt es trotzdem, ist halt so ein Frühwarnsystem. Weil klar, es gibt die Blogosphäre, da wird aber viel diskutiert, wir wissen alle, dann hat man gerade mal sein Tiramisu zu Ende essen und so weiter, dann kommt man nicht dazu und dann war's das so. Aber wenn man zumindest versucht, mit so Politnerds, die es ja sicherlich auch geben wird, ich ziehe mich jetzt selber nicht dazu, aber...
Es gibt eine Menge Politnerds, das darf man nie unterschätzen.
Ja, genau.
Man findet auch genug Politnerds, die interessiert genug sind.
Ich frage mich, wie viele davon Chaosradio Express hören, aber wenn sie es tun...
Vielleicht muss man ihnen diese Sendung weiterleiten.
Wäre das ja nun auch wirklich mal ein Projekt. Nicht, dass ich der Meinung bin, es gibt für alles eine technische Lösung, aber auf jeden Fall kann natürlich eine Technik auch sehr unterstützend wirken. Dass man einfach ein System hat, was, ich fantasiere jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen, ein gegebenenfalls ein bisschen auch so auf Social-Network-Reputationsbasis eine Gewichtung in ein gefundenes Thema hat, so nach dem Motto, wo jemand entdeckt, ah, der Innenausschuss beschäftigt sich mit einer Verschärfung des Videoüberwachungsgesetzes. Mal ein blödes Beispiel. So, dann hat das irgendwie da so seine passenden Texts, wo das dann automatisch in so einen gewissen Themenkram reinfällt und Leute, die sich für solche Themen halt interessieren oder der Meinung sind, da Aussagen machen zu können, abonnieren das eben, dann fällt das eben automatisch rein. Irgendjemand hat sozusagen zusammengesucht. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt nicht bundestag.de lesen und vor allem auch noch diese Sprache verstehen. Sondern dass man schon mal so einen Filter hat davor und es gibt dann ein System, aus dem solche Politaktivität rausfällt.
Man könnte sich das vorstellen. Man kann es natürlich auch noch den Schritt weiter denken, dass man dann entsprechend kontextsensitiv Dinge hinzubekommt, wie zum Beispiel Neuigkeiten zum Thema. Ja, also eine intelligente Variante von Google News dazu zu binden, ein riesengroßes Mashup daraus zu bauen, wo man dann halt die aktuelle Entwicklung genau dieses Gesetzesvorhabens zum Beispiel weiter tracken kann, wo man dann vielleicht auch schon wieder Abgeordneten-Wordschinden wieder anflanscht, dass man sagt, okay, das Thema liegt beim Innenausschuss, wer ist denn zuständiger Berichterstatter und kann ich den jetzt nicht mal ganz schnell kontaktieren?
Sollen wir jetzt, heißt die Sendung jetzt schon Politik von Nerds irgendwie? Also sind Nerds eine, können Nerds eine Driving Force sein im Politikbusiness?
Ich denke ja, solange sie sich, ich glaube, Nerds könnten sehr wohl eine Driving Force sein. Ich fand das sehr schön beim Kongress jetzt gerade, Ende letzten Jahres. Da gab es eine wunderbare Szene, man nannte es, glaube ich, Demonstration.
Ja, wo so Leute rausgehen mit Schildern.
Wo Leute mit Schildern, also links ein Schild, rechts den Laptop aufgeklappt, einmal über den Alex gezogen, was ich schon...
Ach so mit dem Laptop in der Hand.
Ja, teilweise mit dem Laptop rechts in der Hand. Einige stellten ihre spontane Sympathie mit Paragraph 129a fest. Ja, fand ich äußerst interessant zu sehen. Na ja, wenn plötzlich ein Teil des Demonstrationszuges mit seiner doch gewiss überschaubaren Menge, wir sind alle 129a, skandiert. Bin ich davon überrascht im Rahmen dieses Kongresses. Da war ich überrascht, von alle 202c hätte mich weniger überrascht. Der Hacker-Paragraph.
Anstatt des Terrorismus-Paragraphen. Okay, das war wohl etwas überspitzt formuliert.
Vielleicht auch. Ich war davon etwas überrascht. Aber fand ich zum Beispiel mal ein sehr schönes Erlebnis, einfach nur die Reaktionen von Passanten zu verfolgen.
Haben die das überhaupt verstanden?
Nein, sie haben nichts verstanden.
Und wie war die Reaktion?
Schnell weg.
Aha, also kontraproduktiv.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ist das nicht generell so bei Demonstrationen? Ich denke mir auch mal schnell weg, wenn eine Demonstration kommt, wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Das ist einer dieser Punkte, über die man nachdenken sollte, ob die Demonstration als solches tatsächlich...
Ich habe immer den Eindruck, so eine Demonstration ist nicht so sehr für die Leute, die das sehen, sondern mehr so für die Leute, die daran teilnehmen. Das ist so ein bisschen so eine... Ja, so eine Incentive-Veranstaltung, wie bei Firmen, wenn sie alle da sitzen und dann so, wie sind wir?
Sich einmal gemeinsam zum Horst machen. Warum nicht? Genau.
Nicht so Horst Köhler, aber doch zum Horst... Ja, aber es ist ja auch so ein bisschen... Also man geht dann da hin und dann sieht man so, es gibt noch andere Leute und so weiter, ich bin nicht allein. Also das ist ja nicht von Nachteil, nebenbei hat man immer noch diesen Medieneffekt. Ich weiß nicht genau, auf wen das dann wirklich einen Effekt hat, aber immerhin etwas, was in den Medien ist, verdrängt etwas, was anderes, was auch in den Medien sein könnte. Also lieber mehr eine Demo-Vorratsdatenspeicherung, mehr als noch mehr über Britney Spears erfahren, ob ich das Gefühl habe, dass die wirklich sich gegenseitig einen Platz wegnehmen.
Du hast gerade ein wichtiges Thema angesprochen, die Mediengeschichte. Da sollten wir vielleicht gleich noch mal ganz kurz darauf zu sprechen kommen.
Na dann mal los.
Oder jetzt direkt. Wir haben es beim Thema Online-Durchsuchung sehr schön gesehen. Die Online-Durchsuchung ist ein Thema, was wirklich als medial-politisches Perpetuum mobile bezeichnet. Ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Ein werter Kollege schrieb etwas, jemand las es im Pressespiegel, rezitierte diesen Kollegen, dies wurde als genuine seine Äußerung vom nächsten aufgegriffen. Und es bewegte sich hinfort dieses Thema. Natürlich, es gab einen Anlass dafür, aber...
Wovon redest du denn jetzt? Von dem Begriff Bundes-Trojaner?
Ich rede von dem Begriff Bundes-Trojaner.
Was ist denn deine These, wo es herkommt?
Was ist der Begriff Bundes-Trojaner? Ja. Das erste Mal, dass ich das Wort Bundes-Trojaner gelesen habe, war beim werten Kollegen Christian Rath von der Taz.
Naja.
Das ist...
Wir haben irgendwann mal gegoogelt und die erste... Erste Erwähnung ging irgendwie eher auf den CDC zurück. Es kann auch an den Google-Preferenzes gelegen haben.
An euren oder meinen?
Ja, es ist total unklar, wo der Begriff eigentlich herkommt.
Das ist auch relativ egal. Auf jeden Fall ging es um grobe Unsachlichkeiten einfach in dem ganzen Zusammenhang, die sich dann allerdings als Wunschdenken wieder bei manchen im Kopf festfraßen und auch wieder als Äußerungen dann getätigt wurden. Und im Endeffekt war es dann halt so, dass man vom Faktischen nicht mehr so wirklich sprach, vom Wunschdenken hingegen viel mehr, gerade im sicherheitspolitischen Wunschdenken, die Diskrepanz zwischen dem, was an Mitteln zum Beispiel bewilligt wurde, zwischen dem, was an Mitteln vorhanden war. So, dieses schöne Beispiel von wegen, was für einen Programmierer bekommst du momentan für 40.000 Euro im Jahr?
Also was meinst du, dass es gut gelaufen ist, weil es früher in den Medien gelandet ist?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut gelaufen ist. Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher. Ich glaube, es ist dadurch ein ziemlich großes Scheingefecht geworden und eine ziemliche Nebenbaustelle. Das BKA-Gesetz als solches ist relativ viel interessanter. Aber das muss man dann halt einfach anders sehen. Da gab es genug Leute, die das spielen wollten.
Ich weiß nicht genau, warum du jetzt ausgerechnet da drauf gekommen bist mit der Online-Infektion.
Ich komme direkt darauf, dadurch, dass man da sehr schön daran sehen konnte, wie es auch funktionieren kann, nämlich dass man eine Äußerung tätigt, als Journalist oder Politiker, sie am nächsten Morgen im Pressespiegel steht. Denn am Morgen steht der Pressespiegel da.
Also im Pressespiegel des Bundestages meistens?
Des Bundestages, des Abgeordneten, der Fraktion, des Ausschusses. Es gibt verschiedene. Und im Zweifel macht noch jeder Abgeordnete so ein bisschen so selber an auf Wassergerichte. Und was passiert dann? Es wird konsumiert, klassisch durch den Abgeordneten und seine Mitarbeiter. Und je nach Glaubwürdigkeit des Mediums wird es dann mal für mehr barer Münze genommen, für weniger barer Münze. Das heißt, die nächste Äußerung des Politikers kann sich genau darauf wieder stützen. Du weißt, warum Nachrichtendienste Nachrichtendienste heißen? Naja, weil sie primär Nachrichten auswerten. Das ist kein besonders anspruchsvoller Job, es sei denn, es sind jetzt Nachrichten, die in Paschtu verfasst worden sind. Dafür sollte man schon zumindest Paschtu können. Und die wenigsten Menschen können Paschtu, also ist es vielleicht sinnvoll, die Verbindung von A in Paschtu und B in, weiß der Geier welche andere Sprache, in Farsi von mir aus, die vielleicht zusammenzuführen und dann schauen, was für ein Muster sich ergibt, was für ein Pattern. Das ist nachrichtendienstliche Arbeit. Es geht um Analyse von Nachrichten. Das ist die Primäraufgabe. Alles dahinter mit geheimdienstlichen Aufgaben und so weiter sei mal hinten angestellt. Das ist noch nicht mal geheim, sondern Nachrichtenanalyse sagt einem auch tatsächlich jeder Mensch, der irgendwann mal damit in engerer Berührung war, sagt einem, ist das hauptsächlich das Aufbereiten von Nachrichten zur Informationsgewinnung. Genau das macht natürlich so ein Bundestagsabgeordneter auch jeden Tag für sich. Er muss Information zusammentragen, aufgrund derer er dann entscheidet. Und wenn das nun mal über den Pressespiegel ist oder über Einflüsse Dritter, wie zum Beispiel der Kaffeeklatsch mit dem Disko-Oriana oder was der Geier was ist.
Ja gut, aber wie kriegen wir das jetzt genutzt? Also der Nerd irgendwie für die Politik zwei Neues holen, überlegt sich jetzt neben seiner Social-Network-Site, wie kann er sich halt konkret einbringen? Wie sollte das Verhältnis zu den Medien sein? Du hast ja mit Medien auch deine Erfahrungen. Ich weiß nicht, nennst du dich eigentlich Journalist?
Ich nenne mich im Regelfall Journalist, ja.
Und wie übst du das aus?
Zum Beispiel in dem ich schreibe.
Ja, das tun ja die meisten Journalisten eigentlich, ne?
Ja, die meisten schreiben. Es gibt auch einige, die machen Audio. Manche machen so was, das nennt man, glaube ich, Bewegtbild.
Das meinte ich jetzt nicht, sondern...
Du meinst jetzt den praktischen Arbeitsalltag, ja?
Naja, nein, dieses... Also Journalisten sind ja... Also derzeit sind sie ja gerade mal wieder ein, wie soll ich sagen? Also derzeit ist es ja gerade mal nicht besonders hip, Journalist zu sein. Also man wird so von der...
Kommt immer noch von in welchen Kreisen, aber...
Ja, kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, aber es ist auf jeden Fall... Es gibt da so diverse Gefechte. Natürlich gibt es da so diese Gefechte mit der Blogger und Neumedienwelt. Darauf will ich jetzt weniger eingehen. Aber natürlich auch so diese... Immer diese Selbstbeweihräucherung des Journalistentums, mit was sie doch alles für die Freiheit tun würden und so weiter. Aber sie sind auch noch nicht mehr in der Lage, über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung genug zu berichten, um zu festzustellen, dass ihr eigener Berufsstand dadurch aktiv gefährdet ist. Das ist etwas, was ich zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen konnte. Warum es da einfach nicht schon... Also, ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Nachrichtendienst. Die werten ja auch Nachrichten aus. Wie kann es sein, dass die davon überfahren wurden? Am Ende war es hier sogar vielleicht noch egal. So.
Möchte ich per se, kann ich natürlich so pauschal keine Antwort darauf geben, wie es sich in dem gesamten Berufsstand verhält. Ich kann dir sagen, was ich selber dazu gemacht habe. Ich habe darüber geschrieben, ich habe über genau diese Themen geschrieben, aber ich habe auch festgestellt, dass es schwierig ist, sich angemessen in dieses Thema einzuarbeiten. Gerade vor Ort ist es eine Anfeicherung, weil es ein enorm komplexes Thema ist, mit wahnsinnig vielen Facetten. Und sehr, sehr viel Aufwand ist. Und wenn du Journalist bist, lebst du davon, dass du das verhältest von Aufwand?
Ja gut, aber wenn jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, Hausdurchsuchungen stattfinden oder mal wieder ein Fotoreporter in einer Krisenregion erschossen wird, dann ist der Protest immer sehr schnell sehr groß. Und hier geht es ja nun auch um ein Gesetz, wo dann die Informantenschutz einfach aufgehoben wird.
Also ganz faktisch ist es doch so, als der durchschnittliche Journalist in seinem ganzen Leben keine einzige investigative Story schreibt. Ja, wie denn auch? Was ist denn alles ein Journalist?
Du bist einer.
Ja, ich bin einer.
Und hast du schon mal eine investigative Story geschrieben?
Ich würde sagen nein. Ich würde sagen, ich habe mich themangemessen angenommen. Als investigativ würde ich das nicht bezeichnen.
Ja, ist ja nicht jeder Detektiv.
Muss ja auch nicht. Also nicht jeder macht den Wallraff und macht ein paar Wochen lang den Mann, der bei der Bild Herr Esser war. Gut, gehört halt auch nicht unbedingt zum Berufsbild eines jeden Journalisten dazu. Der Großteil der Journalisten schreibt halt darüber, auch über interessante Themen, sagen wir es mal so, die auch genug Menschen interessieren. Das fängt an bei demjenigen, der den Artikel über die Erhöhung der Hundesteuer in Berlin schreibt, über den nächsten, der über die Autobahneröffnung in Westsachsen schreibt usw.
Okay, ist ja auch egal. Wir sind ein bisschen abgekommen, wie immer. Ist ja auch schön. Du hast das Beispiel der Demonstrationen gebracht, auf dem Alexanderplatz usw. Und welche Rolle auch die Medien spielt. Was gibt es denn da jetzt, was man sozusagen politisch auch wirklich bewegen kann? Sagst du, man soll jetzt einfach nicht mehr an Demonstrationen teilnehmen, sondern seine Zeit in andere Sachen stecken?
Demonstrationen haben ja heutzutage einen ganz neuen Wert, sagen wir es mal so. Demonstrationen werden ja selten.
Ach.
Ja, Demonstrationen sind selten geworden.
Wirklich?
Ja, die Anzahl an Demonstrationen in Deutschland hat abgenommen über die letzten 15 Jahre.
Ich habe in Berlin Mitte gewohnt, da hat man das Gefühl, es hat extrem zugenommen.
Es gibt Leute, die haben auch der festen Meinung, dass es deswegen abgenommen hätte, weil der Kurdistan-Konflikt etwas weniger offensiv eine lange Zeit lang ausgetragen wurde, wo sehr viele Demonstrationen von A und B und C immer stattgefunden haben. Also von der Summe her. Nein, aber grundsätzlich die Zahl der Demonstrationen hat abgenommen. Was politische Demonstrationen angeht, vor allem der großen Demonstrationen hat sehr stark abgenommen. Das heißt, für so ein Thema wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, etc., dafür 15.000 Leute auf die Straße zu kriegen, das ist schon angesichts der Abstraktionslevels, habe ich das für durchaus respektabel gefunden.
Wird denn das dann wahrgenommen im Bundestag? Von deiner Erfahrung her, so eine Demonstration für die Stadt, jetzt ist das in einer Tagesschau, was heißt das? Ist das dann automatisch in der Presse spiegeln, und dann wird das automatisch gelesen?
Das ist natürlich der Nachteil einer Tagesschau-Geschichte. Du weißt, die Pressespiegel, selbst wenn sie digital vorliegen, werden im Zweifel nochmal ausgedruckt. Eine Tagesschau-Sendung auszudrucken, ist relativ ineffizient. Macht man also eher nicht.
Das heißt, kümmert sich eigentlich kein Mensch mehr drum?
Naja, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand die Tagesschau guckt, ist allerdings immer noch relativ hoch auch, und gerade bei Politikern, es sei denn, sie haben gerade um 20 Uhr einen Termin.
Und vor allem, das gibt es jetzt als Podcast.
Näh, Angela Merkel gibt es auch als Podcast. Ich weiß nicht, was man dann lieber guckt.
Tagesschau, definitiv im iTunes-Direktorie weit vor Angela Merkel.
Also ich bin mir vor allem nicht ganz sicher, was die werten Herren und Damen MDB lieber schauen und intensiver schauen.
Ja, aber kommt das jetzt an?
Es kommt sicherlich etwas an.
Aber eigentlich ist Ihnen das egal?
Es ist Ihnen sicherlich auch nicht egal, weil das ist ein Thema, das erstmal Aufmerksamkeit dadurch erzeugt. Du musst immer erstmal Aufmerksamkeit für ein Thema erzeugen, ganz klassisch, erst die Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen, um überhaupt eine Beschäftigung mit einem Thema zu erzeugen. Anders funktioniert es nicht. Das heißt, wenn du keine Aufmerksamkeit erzeugst, wirst du auch keine Beschäftigung mit dem Thema erzeugen können. Es wäre aber auch eine Intrinsische Motivation des jeweiligen Abgeordneten. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Informatiker wir im Bundestag haben, aber ich glaube, es sind vier oder fünf. Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Angesichts der Extrovertiertheit des durchschnittlichen Informatikers weiß ich das nicht.
Aber es könnte zumindest für mehr Sachkenntnis führen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel nichts gegen Herrn Taus persönlich. Ich finde es aber schon interessant.
Er ist doch kein Informatiker, oder?
Nein, der Herr Taus ist kein Informatiker. Ich glaube, er ist so seit Ende der Weningen ohne Hochschulausbildung. Aber egal. Herr Taus ist derjenige, der die Zwischenrufstatistik des Bundestages, glaube ich, kontinuierlich seit Jahren anführt.
Da gibt es eine Statistik?
Es gibt eine Zwischenrufstatistik, ja. Ich glaube auch mit dem Best-ofs oder so ähnlich.
Gibt es sie auch auf der Webseite?
Ja, die Zwischenrufstatistik. Zumindest für die letzte Legislaturperiode müsste es auf der Webseite geben. Wie gesagt, Herr Traus war da ganz vorne dabei mit einer erquicklichen Anzahl. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das...
Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn man im Parlament so aufspringt und sagt, sie... Dann wird das gleich...
Na ja, die springen ja im Regelfall nicht auf. Wir sind ja nicht mehr im Unterhaus Großbritanniens. Sondern wir sind in Deutschland, da bleibt man einfach sitzen und krakält rein.
Also Zwischenrufstatistik bringt ja irgendwie...
Mach mal Zwischenrufe. Unterhaus, dann findest du schon was.
Okay, rede weiter.
Auf jeden Fall, das ist einer der typischen Sachen, wo ich sagen muss, das ist nicht unbedingt ein Qualitätskriterium, ganz ehrlich, für einen Abgeordneten, wenn er besonders viele Zwischenrufe hat. Wenn man damit in Schlagzeilen landet, weiß ich nicht. Wie gesagt, ohne persönlich etwas gegen ihn zu haben. Ich glaube, er beschäftigt sich schon mit den richtigen Themen. Aber es hat natürlich auch was mit Rangfolge innerhalb eines Parlaments zu tun, wer sich mit welchen Themen beschäftigt. Wenn Herr Taus sich mit der Onlandurchsuchung beschäftigen würde, würde das anders aussehen, als wenn das Herr Wiefelspitz tut. Herr Wiefelspitz würde sich aber anders damit beschäftigen. Gleiche Fraktion, theoretisch verwandter Bereich. Aber wer kümmert sich tatsächlich um Onlandurchsuchungen und Co. Wiefelspitz und Edati, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe bei der SPD. Das heißt, da sind die Leute, die den technischen Sachverstand vielleicht tatsächlich sogar haben. Das möchte ich bei Taus zum Beispiel gar nicht unbedingt in Abrede stellen. Der hat zumindest die Möglichkeit, sich entsprechend zu informieren. Der ist dann nicht mehr gefragt. Wann kommen die Leute, die tatsächlich knallhart innen- und rechts- also in den innenpolitischen Ausschuss sind und klassische Innenpolitik machen und dann sehr nah dran sind?
Also was, ja, ich wollte jetzt noch mal das noch nicht ganz loslassen, die Idee, was können Nerds und technisch gebildete Menschen für den Bundestag und damit vielleicht auch hier für das politische System tun, über Demonstrationen hinaus? Also was ist jetzt deiner Meinung nach so der beste Weg, sich einzubringen, nachdem man jetzt mit seinem lokalen Wahl-Bundestagsabgeordneten in seinem, nicht in seinem Wahllokal, sondern in seinem Besuchsort, was auch immer, sein Bürgerbüro, sich auseinandergesetzt hat. Man hat ein bisschen demonstriert, man hat ein bisschen geblockt. Was kann man noch machen?
Man könnte zum Beispiel unglaublich kreativ sein und in eine Partei eintreten. Das ist vielleicht gar nicht die schlechteste Idee.
Da sind viele Leute anderer Meinung.
Ja, ich weiß, da sind viele Leute anderer Meinung. Aber man könnte es tun.
Und was ist dann, wenn man es macht?
Dann zahlt man erstmal Mitgliedsbeitrag. Das ist primär noch nicht so wahnsinnig schlimm. Geld zahlt man an vielen Stellen. Vielleicht fährt man dafür...
Ist das eigentlich teuer?
Parteimitgliedschaften, je nachdem, welche Partei.
Bist du irgendwo schon mal Mitglied gewesen?
Privatsachen gehen dich gar nichts an.
Du musst nur sagen ja oder nein.
Ja, siehst du, ich bin in vielen Vereinen Mitglied. Ob in einer Partei, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Na ja, der Unterschied mag gering sein. Wie auch immer.
Ist es teuer? Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht umsonst. Ich glaube, man kann bei 5 Euro etwa starten, wenn man nichts hat. Das ist ja wie beim CCC. Und ich glaube, nach obenhin gibt es keine Grenze, wenn man unbedingt möchte. Aber der Dienst kann man das, glaube ich, auch zum größten von Steuern absetzen.
Ist der nicht schleurig begünstigt? Das wäre mir neu. Aber zumindest ist es nicht nach oben offen. Aber es gibt einen Höchstbeitrag. Ich denke, wenn uns jemand mehr überweist, haben wir auch nichts dagegen. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was da tatsächlich gezahlt wird oder nicht.
Wenn du in einer Partei Mitglied bist, hast du natürlich auch gewisse Mitgliedsrechte. Das heißt zum Beispiel, dass du als Mitglied, je nachdem, wie die Partei organisiert ist, aber du kannst in den verschiedenen Parteien ab einem gewissen Grad unterschiedliche Anträge stellen. Du kannst Anträge auf Tagesordnungspunkte stellen. Du kannst versuchen, Gruppen zu bilden mit anderen Interessierten, zum Beispiel mit mehreren Leuten in einer Partei, vielleicht aus verschiedenen Wahlkreisen. Du kannst zum Beispiel auf einem Landesparteitag vielleicht schon etwas machen, vielleicht schon einen Antrag zu einem Thema formulieren und den zur Abstimmung bringen, um dann festzustellen, dass du vielleicht doch in der falschen Partei bist. Okay, kann dir passieren. Aber es kann auch sein, dass du dann in genau der richtigen Partei bist und dann hast du einen offiziellen Beschluss und damit kannst du wiederum hingehen mit einem offiziellen Beschluss deiner Partei. Du kannst natürlich zu einem Abgeordneten gehen und sagen, hey Moment, das ist doch hier. Das hat doch hier unser Landesparteitag beschlossen. Sag mal, warum stehst du da eigentlich ganz anders da? Warum machst du ganz andere Politik als das, was deine Partei will? Du bist doch irgendwie auch über Landesliste mal reingekommen. Meinst du, das ist so... Dann setzen diese klassischen Machtmechanismen ein, dass man sagt, hey Moment, du, was machst du da eigentlich? Beim nächsten Mal drei Listenplätze tiefer?
Ist das so ein bisschen Parteihacking?
Ja, je nach Partei ist es unterschiedlich schwer oder einfach.
Es gab ja immer diese Studenteninitiative in Berlin, die FDP zu übernehmen. Das hat glaube ich am Ende nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Nee, es hat nicht so richtig funktioniert. Ich habe auch nicht ganz verstanden, warum.
Sie waren der Meinung, dass die FDP sowieso total überflüssig ist, aber da es sie sozusagen als Body schon mal so gibt, könnte man sie ja einfach mal übernehmen und dann so quasi als Trojaner für die studentischen Anliegen missbrauchen.
Das klingt nach einem politischen Leichenschmoss. Das würde man einen politischen Kurdel nennen. Ein politischer Kurdel.
Ja, wie auch immer. Es hatte den interessanten Effekt, dass bei der FDP auf einmal tatsächlich so ein Ruck durchging, dass alle so ein bisschen mit der Angst bekommen haben und sich dann wahrscheinlich alle mal wieder ein bisschen zahlreicher eingefunden haben. Also war am Ende vielleicht auch noch ganz hilfreich. War glaube ich ja auch lokal in Berlin.
Ich kann mich auch noch an die Geschichte erinnern.
Also in eine Partei eintreten ist sinnvoller, als selber eine zu gründen. Es gibt ja jetzt dieses Phänomen der Piratenpartei.
Ich persönlich halte das für sehr viel sinnvoller, insofern als dass man sich ja trotz allem prinzipiell immer mit mehreren Dingen beschäftigt.
Was für sinnvoller?
Ich halte es für wesentlich sinnvoller, in eine Partei, die besteht einzutreten, und gegebenenfalls den Wunsch zu haben, sie zu verändern, als eine komplett neue Partei zu gründen. Das halte ich für relativ sinnbefreit. Aus einem ganz einfachen Grund. Ich kann eine Partei wie die Piratenpartei, um mal in diesem Beispiel zu bleiben, in Deutschland halte ich für qualitativ deutlich schwieriger als zum Beispiel die Schwedische. Die Schwedische Piratenpartei ist von Menschen gegründet worden, die wirklich tatsächlich Ahnung haben von Politik. Die richtig Ahnung haben von Politik, die knallhart auch wissen, was sie dort treiben, tun und lassen, und die auch ein relativ klares und stringentes Programm haben. Das ist nicht Single-Issue, das ist nicht One-Issue-Party, sondern es ist tatsächlich mehr als das. Sie haben tatsächlich verschiedene Positionen, politische Positionen, die sind nicht komplett ausdifferenziert, aber okay, sie sind schon deutlich erfolgreicher sprechender als das, was ich zumindest bislang von der deutschen Piratenpartei wahrgenommen habe, aber ich muss zugeben, ich hab da auch so ein bisschen meine Probleme mit gehabt, als sie kurz nach ihrer Gründung als Erstes anfing, Pöstchen zu verteilen, und ich glaube, der Posten des Generalsekretärs war als Erstes besetzt. Das fand ich persönlich jetzt nicht unbedingt so wahnsinnig prickelnd, ob Pöstchenjagen die Hauptaufgabe einer frisch gegründeten Partei sein müsse.
Na, du bist ein guter Pirat, das ja geht natürlich erstmal gleich auf die Schatzruhe los.
Ja, vielleicht nimmt er auch einmal erst mal das Steuerrad, das kann auch sein, und der nächste sitzt oben im Mast und guckt, dass auch nichts anbrennt.
Ja, und der Rest darf sich dann auf die Ruhler verteilen.
Genau. Ja, willkommen auf der Galere. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das so der perfekte Weg ist, aber ich glaube, es ist wesentlich sinnvoller, sich in einer bestehenden Partei zu engagieren. Einfach deswegen, weil man dort zum einen Infrastruktur hat, die man nutzen kann. Das ist jetzt noch nicht mal im Sinne von Hacking gedacht, sondern einfach nur, es gibt diese Infrastruktur, und wenn man gute Themen hat, die auch mit dieser Partei irgendwie konform gehen, dann gibt es keinen Grund, das nicht zu tun. Eine Partei hat immer so viel politische Meinung zu einem Thema, wie es Menschen gibt, die sich innerhalb einer Partei für dieses politische Thema interessieren.
Freuen sie denn die Leute in der Partei, wenn da neue dazu kommen?
Häufig genug ja. Natürlich ist es schwierig, ein Pöstchen zu ergattern und so weiter. Aber wenn du es gar nicht auch das Pöstchen abgesehen hast, sondern sagst, ich lass dir dein Pöstchen, wenn du das Thema machst, dann freuen sie sich. Dann haben sie zumindest weniger dagegen. Das ist schon zumindest deutlich eins.
Aber vielleicht braucht man ja auch das Pöstchen, um irgendwie...
Dann sollte man schauen, dass man entsprechende Mehrheiten organisiert bekommt.
Also nach dem Motto, wenn Person X mit dem Thema nicht anfangen möchte, dann...
Ja, dann muss man sich halt schon überlegen. Aber der Vorteil von bestehenden Parteien gegenüber einer Neugründung ist der, dass du ein gewisses Set hast an Dingen, mit denen du quasi arbeiten kannst. Du hast ein gewisses Set an verschiedenen Variablen, die schon ausgefüllt sind. Also es kann ja sein, dass du zum Beispiel bei dem einen Thema total nah an der CDU bist, bei dem anderen Thema aber total nah an der PDS. Zumindest theoretisch an der Linken, Entschuldigung. Kann ja sein, stimmt. Aber du wirst dich irgendwo entscheiden müssen. Du wirst keine Partei gründen, die beides vereint. Die wird zumindest nicht mehrheitsfähig werden. Vermutlich, obwohl bei den beiden bin ich mir nicht sicher. Kann da passieren. Also es ist zumindest unwahrscheinlich, dass du es schaffst. Eine Partei zu gründen, die eine gewisse Hürde überschreitet, also die 5%-Hürde zum Beispiel und damit jemals wirklich politisch relevant wird, es ist unwahrscheinlich, dass du es schaffst, eine Mehrheit zu organisieren und auch eine Anzahl an Leuten zu organisieren, die sich aktiv beteiligen, sodass sie Relevanz entfalten kann und auch genug Diskurs bietet, letzten Endes, um qualitativ halbwegs vertretbare Entscheidungen zu generieren. Man kann ja sagen, was man möchte, man kann ja über Volksparteien usw. schimpfen, aber sie sind ein Ausdruck von Willensbildung, von politischer Willensbildung. Man kann gegen diesen Willen, kann man dagegen sein und sonst was. Aber sie funktionieren als solche schon nach einem Prinzip, wo man sagen muss, hey, Respekt, dass das überhaupt so gut funktioniert. Denn das ist schon ein hochkomplexes Gebilde, es ist ein hochlebendiges Gebilde, auch wenn man bei manchen Ortsgruppensitzungen sicherlich ein anderes Gefühl hat. Aber grundsätzlich sind das erst mal Menschen, die zusammenkommen, zusammen Entscheidungen versuchen zu treffen, zusammen Willen bilden. Und das wird schon ein zweites Teil.
Ist das so ein bisschen Kickelklub alle Neune? Man trifft sich dann irgendwie so einmal die Woche und dann wird so mal ein bisschen darüber gesprochen? Oder gibt es dann so knallharte Sitzungsgeschichte?
Je nachdem, wo du bist.
Ja, mal ein Beispiel vielleicht so.
Ein Beispiel?
Muss es da ja nicht selber Mitglied gewesen sein, sondern bist du auch nur so rein zufällig vorbeigekommen?
Ich bin auch schon tatsächlich sehr zufällig bei Parteisitzungen vorbeigekommen. Das lag zum Beispiel daran, dass sie dann teilweise in einer Kneipe stattgefunden haben, wo ich gerade am Tisch gegenüber saß. Das soll auch schon mal vorgekommen sein. Im Regelfall macht man es aber nicht in der Kneipe, es sei denn auf einem platten Land irgendwo oder auf dem bergigen Land. Das ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall kann es einfach sein, dass man dann gerade konkrete Diskussionen hat. Dann gibt es dann ein Thema, das gerade diskutiert wird. Das kann wirklich auf Stammtischniveau sein.
Ich meine, gibt es da jetzt irgendwie... Ich war noch nicht bei so einer Partei. Kriegt man da vorher so einen Zettel, nächste Woche reden wir über... Oder kommt man da einfach hin und sagt...
Das sind so bis zu aktuellen Themen. Die meisten Parteien haben so eine Art offene Tagesordnung. Am Anfang wird immer gefragt, hat noch jemand anderes einen anderen Punkt.
Und dann sitzen alle so im Tisch rum und dann redet man mal drüber.
Macht so ein Plenum.
Gibt irgendwie Hotdogs noch dazu.
Ich kann schon mal drüber nachdenken, ob demnächst nicht was zu entscheiden ist.
Und dann befinde ich mich üblicherweise in was für einem Kreis. Das ist dann so ein Regionalverband oder was?
Normalerweise bist du dann... Das ist erst mal eine Ortsgruppe oder Ortsvereinssitzung.
Damit fängt man an.
Das ist eigentlich so das Standardlevel. Das ist dann so, dass du dann im Regelfall einen Ortsvorsitzenden hast usw. Der ist dann wieder für den Kreis oder den Bezirk zuständig. Das ist dann so die klassische Kaskade nach oben. Spitzzulaufende Pyramide. Irgendwann hast du dann einen Parteivorsitzenden am Ende. Und das sind halt diese Kreise.
Wird er wirklich auf einer Ortsgruppen-Ebene... Wird er nicht im Wesentlichen so Local Shit behandelt?
Wir sind dich in zufälliger Weise ja, denn der Local Shit ist vielleicht das, was dich konkret betrifft.
Okay, das mag natürlich sein. Wir haben jetzt über diese höheren Dinge geredet, aber am Ende ist vielleicht wirklich die Umgehungsstraße dann auch wichtiger.
Vielleicht ist es wichtiger, dass du noch einen Kindergartenplatz für dein Kind hast, als dass du über den Afghanistan-Einsatz diskutierst. Okay, mag sein, dass der Kindergartenplatz...
Jetzt hast du ja eine offene Wunde im Prenzlauer Berg angesprochen.
Das war ein Kollateralschaden.
Das ist ja irgendwie fünf Jahre lang verpeilt, dass ihr irgendwie viele neue Kinder habt, und dann gibt es auf einmal keine Schulplätze dafür.
Ach so, ja, ja. Das ist, glaube ich, insgesamt in Berlin ein sehr interessantes Phänomen, insbesondere was die Verteilungsgerechtigkeit und Ähnliches angeht.
Darüber wollen wir jetzt nicht reden. Wir wollen ja reden, wie kann der Nerd von heute die Welt verändern?
Wie kann der Nerd von heute die Welt verändern? Er kann solche Gremien instrumentalisieren, nutzen. Also instrumentalisieren ist nicht so ein schönes Wort. Nutzen halte ich für das schönere. Hacken kann man dazu auch sagen, meine mannen.
Wie hackt man es denn? Also gibt es nicht irgendwelche Shortcuts und Abkürzungen? Jetzt müssen wir hier mal ins Eingemachte kommen.
Ja, natürlich gibt es die Shortcuts und Abkürzungen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel immer wieder...
So Hebel, irgendwie...
Verrat doch mal ein paar Tricks.
Was heißt Tricks? Hey, hallo, das sind keine Tricks. Das sind ja noch nicht mal Tricks. Überraschenderweise, in einer Partei läuft es über Social Engineering, oder?
Echt überraschend, oder? Du meinst, Parteiarbeit ist per se schon mal eine Hackerdisziplin?
Irgendwie schon. Und ich glaube, dadurch, dass du dich damit beschäftigst, wie du Systeme vielleicht am einfachsten penetrierst und so weiter, das könnte ein sehr erfolgversprechender Weg sein.
Ach du meinst, hey, ihr habt ja überhaupt keinen Systemadministrator, ich kenne mich super mit dem Abstimmungssystem aus. Aber abgestimmt wird schon... Ich auch nicht, ich hab das nur so zitiert.
Ich sage auch gar nicht, dass es ein Abstimmungssystem ist als solches. Nein, es kann auch wirklich die Sache sein, dass du einfach sagst, wie, ihr habt gar keinen Administrator, ich kenne mich super mit dem System aus. Und das muss noch nicht mal der Wahlcomputer sein.
Systemadministratoren sind immer gefragt. So ist es, ich kann das bestätigen. Alle Leute leben Systeme und ich liebe auch mein Systemadministrat.
Und andere Leute können halt doch nur sagen, dass sie PHP können, können es aber nicht, und sind trotzdem gefragt. Also auch das kann durchaus funktionieren.
Das stimmt, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein guter Start.
Vielleicht musst du gar nicht Bildungspolitik können. So wie du sagst, dass du Bildungspolitik kannst. Weiß ich nicht. Hast du dein Pöstchen?
Aber wenn man sagt, dass man irgendwie alle Leute computerfixen kann, dann kommt man auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gut an in der Ortsgruppe.
Da kommt man auf jeden Fall sicher ganz gut an die Daten in der Ortsgruppe.
Ah, jetzt haben wir doch schon mal einen Einstieg gefunden. An die Daten jetzt. Das hast du jetzt gesagt. Ich habe nichts gesagt von Daten.
Was natürlich keine Aufforderung zu illegalen Dingen sind.
Nein, nein, nein. Wir wollen ja nur, dass wir engineeringen. Ja genau, wir sollen ja sicher sein. Das ist richtig. Nee, aber es könnte auf jeden Fall helfen, um jetzt mal ein bisschen von der Witzebene wieder runterzukommen. Fällt mir dabei ein. Wir beklagen ja immer häufig, gerade wenn es jetzt um computertechnische Dinge geht, ist ja nicht das einzige, was uns interessiert, aber gerade dann, wenn es um die digitale Welt geht, gibt es immer so dieses Problem, dass man das Gefühl hat, dass diese Politiker überhaupt nicht wissen, wovon wir reden.
Ganz ehrlich, das komme ich von ungefähr.
Ja, und meinst du, das könnte man sozusagen über die Ortsgruppen von unten nach oben anschieben, dass sich das ändert? Oder ändert sich das von alleine?
Es wird sich zum Teil von alleine ändern, natürlich. Also die Anzahl, es ist zum Beispiel sehr bekannt, dass Angela Merkel sehr häufig SMS schreibt. Sie wurde auch schon als SMS-Kanzlerin betitelt.
Echt?
Ja, sie sitzt da und tippt fröhlich vor sich hin. Auch teilweise im Plenarsaal. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie Schatzi schreibt oder ob sie dann irgendwelche anderen Ministern schreibt. Aber das zum Beispiel ist eine Sache, die bekannt ist. Sie nutzt derartige Dinge. Das hätte man zum Beispiel von Gerhard Schröder, geschweige denn von Helmut Kohl, eher nicht erwartet. Helmut Kohl beim Schreiben einer SMS?
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen unfair. Ich meine, als Helmut Kohl irgendwie Kanzler war, da gab es ja noch gar keine SMS. Also als er Kanzler geworden ist, gab es noch keine SMS. Das muss man jetzt mal...
Okay, und die Mobiltelefone waren danach auch etwas klobig, das gebe ich zu. Vielleicht formfaktorgerecht. Wie auch immer.
Herr Kohl ist der Kanzler der Wählscheibe.
Ich dachte immer, das wäre Riesenhuber gewesen.
Der war doch kein Kanzler.
Der war Forschungsminister. Großartig mit der Fliege. Nein, der Kanzler der Wählscheibe? Nein, ich glaube eher dieser grünen, komischen Telefone, die schon dieses kleine Tippfeld hatten.
T01LX.
Ja, T01LX, ich weiß nicht mehr.
T01 ist das mit der normalen Tastatur, T01LX ist das mit den Extra-Tasten. Das hatte ich.
Stimmt.
Ist das Telefon TM überhaupt?
Wir schweifen übrigens ein bisschen ab.
Ja, aber das muss erst mal gesagt werden. T01LX, ja, Hammer. Ich muss mal auf Ebay gucken, ob es das nicht mittlerweile säckeweise gibt. Ich habe so einen Schrott, diese Scheiße. Also jetzt schweife ich wirklich ab. T01LX auf jeden Fall, aber die Wählscheiben waren auch super. Da konnte man eine 11 wählen, wusstest du das? Ja, Anfang der 80er-Jahre konnte man kostenlos telefonieren, indem man einfach eine normale Rufnummer gewählt hat mit Vorwahl. Aber anstatt der Null am Anfang, die ja 10 Impulse war, konnte man einfach 11 Impulse geben, indem man statt die Wählscheibe durchzuwählen, konnte man einfach mit dem Stift oder mit dem Finger auf der Gabel rumtackern. Und wenn man dann eine 11 erwischt hat, also 11 Tacker, und dann einfach nochmal weitergewählt hat, dann war es kostenlos. Das war alles zu Zeiten von Kohl. Und heute haben wir vorerst den Anruf.
Das hat wahrscheinlich das Postministerium auf Dauer seinen Job gekostet. Das gibt es hier bekanntermaßen.
Sie haben es dann irgendwann mal abgeschafft. Das war uns das Feature für die Leute, die dir den Anschluss einrichten. Für den Testanruf.
Auch nicht schlecht. Wo waren wir gerade kurz davor?
Bei der Revolution der Welt.
Wir waren bei der Revolution der Welt. Das ist gar kein schlechter Ansatz. Aber ich glaube, wir waren noch vor der Telekom.
Wie der Nerd auf Ortsgruppen sich da irgendwie beliebt machen kann.
Genau.
Und was überhaupt noch empfehlenswerte Wege sind, auf Politik konkret Einfluss zu nehmen.
Genau. Was immer ein interessanter Weg ist, ist zum Beispiel bei Veranstaltungen aufzutauchen. Dafür zu sorgen, dass man bei Veranstaltungen eingeladen wird. Was für Veranstaltungen? Es gibt eigentlich immer wieder Veranstaltungen, auf denen auch Politiker da sind. Zum Beispiel Wahlkreisveranstaltungen. Wahlkreisveranstaltungen. Also tatsächlich Veranstaltungen wie 150 Jahre Lampenwerk in Elsterwerda.
Das bringt es mir auf eine Idee. Jetzt muss ich gleich mal gucken, ob hier mal eine Ortsgruppe irgendeiner Partei eigentlich auch ein RSS-Feed hat.
Das wäre zum Beispiel eine Sache, die sich nachzugucken lohnt.
Was macht man denn dann am besten? Dann meldet man sich und geht ans... Nein, nein, wenn man jetzt auf dieser Veranstaltung teilnimmt. Meist jetzt nur um sich zu informieren und mal zu wissen, was Sache ist, oder gibt es dann auch noch andere...
Und wenn man einen thematischen Bezug hat, dann kann man natürlich auch durchaus, wenn es zum Beispiel eine kleine Diskussion gibt oder eine Fragemöglichkeit gibt, dann kann man natürlich auch eine Frage an seine Abgeordneten stellen oder das öffentliche stellen, also zum Beispiel auch nicht verkehrt. Oder man könnte natürlich auch auf so eine Veranstaltung auf ihn zugehen, wenn man keine Zeit hat, in seine Bürgersprechstunde zu gehen zum Beispiel. Auch das ist eine Möglichkeit, um ihm zu sagen, hallo, schönen guten Tag. Wir kennen uns bislang noch nicht, aber... Warum nicht? Das bietet sich alles an. Es hat sehr viel mit menschlichem Kontakt zu tun. Diese Leute sind natürlich auch Kommunikationsprofis da drin, also nicht alle, viele auch nicht, aber zumindest einige davon, die prominenteren, sind im übrigen Fall sehr...
Also wenn ich es immer wieder runterbreche, man kann noch so viel RSS-Feeds und Social-Networking-Sites und Watchtimes machen, eigentlich nichts schlägt den direkten Kontakt.
Nichts schlägt den direkten Kontakt, nein, nichts. Gar nichts. Das hat was damit zu tun, dass am Ende auch nicht der RSS-Feed die Entscheidung trifft.
Ja, ist ja auch bei uns eigentlich auch nicht anders. Wenn uns einer anquatscht, dann ist es auch geiler als eine E-Mail.
Ich hab das geiler als eine E-Mail, das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wer es ist.
Ja, natürlich, von der Wirkung. Aber da weiß man ja zumindest sofort so, ah, alles klar. Das ist jetzt nicht wieder irgendeine Nervbacke, sondern wie der rüberkommt, ist auch die Netze. Das heißt, man muss sich auch noch mitkleiden. Was gibt es denn so für Kleiderordnungen?
Kleiderordnungen, bei den meisten normal.
Normal? Du meinst, wenn man so in den Standard-Nerd-Anorak-Ausrüstungen daherkommt, wird man schon ernst genommen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man unbedingt das Töten-T-Shirt tragen sollte. Oder mit ähnlichen... Je nachdem, was man für Abgeordnete besucht, könnte es einen gewissen Unterschied machen. Wenn man z.B. in Bayern wohnt, in ländlichen Bezirken, und dort mit allzu kryptischer Klamotte auftaucht, dann könnte es passieren, dass man weniger ernst genommen wird. Vielleicht ist dort tatsächlich der Zweirajag angesagt. Keine Ahnung, je nachdem, wo man fliegt. Ein Hans-Christian Schröbele würde einen genauso seltsam angucken, weil man im Zweirajag ankommt. Der würde einen wahrscheinlich eher im Kapuzenpulli erwarten.
Also die SPD-Webseite Prenzlauer Bergs ist irgendwie offline. Aber die Grünen funktioniert.
Und, hat sie ein SSFeed?
Ähm, ich wollte jetzt mal wegen der Veranstaltung gucken, ob die überhaupt Veranstaltungen sind. Rotes Panikorchester stellt Sonderzug auf Abstellgleis. Die kommen mir jetzt ernsthaft mit Udo Lindenberg. Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Du siehst aus, es gibt noch viel zu tun.
Jaja, definitiv. Kandidaturen zur Jahreshauptversammlung steht hier gerade an. Der Kreisverband Pankow versammelt sich zur Jahreshauptveranstaltung am 14.
Februar.
Ah, dort werden zahlreiche Posten neu besetzt. Okay, man könnte Vorstandsvorsitzende werden zwei gesucht. Schatzmeister in, Beisitzer, LA-Delegierte und LDK-Delegierte. Was heißt denn LA-Delegierte?
Landessausschuss und Landesdelegiertenkonferenz.
Ah, was Parteitag bei den anderen heißt. Okay, je zwei pro Geschlecht. Bei den Grünen ist das alles sehr genau wiedergegeben.
Es ist quotiert, das entspricht auch sehr dafür, dass du mehr Frauen bei den Nerds brauchst.
Das stimmt eigentlich. Ah, du meinst, wir hätten sonst überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, uns politisch durchzusetzen? Interessanter Aspekt. Ja, Veranstaltungen. Also hier sehe ich jetzt gerade mal keinen, erst es fehlt, aber vielleicht gibt es ja einen oder vielleicht gibt es ja auch irgendwas anderes.
Ich habe auch vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt da gewisse Tendenzen, sich in diese Richtung stärker zu bewegen. Ich sage nicht, dass das schon vollkommen abgeschlossen sei. Also man merkt es schon, dass die Parteien deutlich bessere Webseiten bekommen in letzter Zeit. Auch sehr viele haben halt dann auch standardisierte CMS wie Jomlau oder sonst was im Einsatz. Manche benutzen auch tatsächlich Wiki und Ähnliches. Das ist halt sehr unterschiedlich. Es wird langsam, aber doch. Ich meine, Parteien, der würde erwarten, dass sie Vorreiter der digitalen Revolution sind. Ich nicht.
Ja, gibt es noch abschließend ein paar Tipps, die wir unbedingt loslassen müssen?
Ja, der Tipp überhaupt natürlich. Der Tipp überhaupt ist, bloß nicht frusten lassen. Klar, du hast gerade vorgelesen, was war es? Sonderzug nach Panko auf dem Abstellgleis.
Irgendwas, ja, ich hab's schnell wieder weggefilmt.
Das klingt so prickelnd wie drei Säcke Sand in China. Reiß auch. Das ist natürlich extrem frustrierend, wenn du dich mit solchen Themen beschäftigen sollst und dich wirklich nicht dafür interessiert, sie ist nämlich vollkommen irrelevant. Aber du solltest immer daran denken, das ist für dich irrelevant. Für den anderen nebenan ist es vielleicht nicht irrelevant. Was de facto nichts anderes heißt als gestehe ihm das zu. Das musst du eh. Und wenn du willst, dass er dir zuhört und vielleicht sagt, hey, du hast ein ganz berechtigtes Anliegen, dann solltest du vielleicht auch ihm erstmal zuhören und dann sagen, er hat kein berechtigtes Anliegen. Also in der Reihenfolge bitte auch. Erst zuhören und dann...
Wer fick ihn will, muss freundlich sein.
Maria Perzil, schönes Lied.
Ist das die Quelle? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Echt?
Ja, wie freundlich kannst du sein. Schönes Lied.
Gibt es das im Internet?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß nur, dass es die Band nicht mehr gibt.
Wie alt ist denn das?
Das müsste so von 94 oder 96 sein.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob eine Privatkopie davon irgendwann zulässig ist. Eines fernen Tages.
Eines fernen Tages wird es so weit sein. Okay, ja, das ist sicherlich gut. Also... Haben wir es?
Ich denke, wir haben es im Groben und Ganzen. Also, was auf jeden Fall...
Ist ein unendliches Thema, auf jeden Fall.
Wir können es runterbrechen auf drei Dinge. Erstens, sich selber informieren. Zweitens, andere informieren, und zwar möglichst persönlich. Und drittens, wenn man feststellt, dass mit Information alleine für sich selbst und andere noch nicht genüge getan ist, sich engagieren und das möglichst in einer Art und Weise, die dem Anliegen gerecht wird.
Und das ist vor allem der direkte Kontakt mit den aktuellen Bedenkenträgern und Amtsinhabern, Bürgerbüros, Veranstaltungen besuchen, in Ortsgruppen aktiv werden, sich als Systemadministrator einschleimen und dann mal gucken, was man da bewegt bekommen.
Anders gesagt, wenn momentan noch so viele Webseiten kein RSS-Feed anbieten, was durchaus der Fall sein kann, ich denke, das ist eine Aufgabe, die man durchaus übernehmen kann, um den RSS-Feed einer Parteiwebsite zu kümmern. Da wird man sicherlich nur dankebare Worte für hören, abgesehen davon, dass die Leute noch sagen werden, wofür das gut ist, weiß ich auch nicht, aber wir haben das jetzt. Gut. Mir fehlt eh noch der RSS-to-brief-gateway.
Aber gut. Ich meine, es ist natürlich auch wichtig, dass man Informationsleuchttürme aufbaut, dass man überhaupt erst mal Orte hat, wo Information gut aggregiert wird. Das würde ich meinen, das ist jetzt auch für mich ein interessanter Punkt, gerade wenn man jetzt eben nicht die Zeit hat, diesen Dingen wirklich nachzugehen. Das ist ja jetzt vor allem immer erst mal was für die Jugend, die ja immer ganz viel bewegen will. Nicht, dass ich jetzt schon freiwillig aus der Jugend ausgeschrieben wäre.
Du dürftest glaube ich in keiner Partei mehr mittlerweile in der Jugendorganisation sein.
Das hast du schön gesagt. Ich würde ja gerne, aber ich darf nicht mehr. Und von daher gibt es da auf jeden Fall auch eine Möglichkeit, seine technische Expertise einzubringen und so ganz nebenbei kann man dann den anderen Parteifreunden, die man dann gewinnt, auch ein Verständnis dafür geben, dass es auch sinnvoll sein kann, moderne Technologien einzusetzen bzw. auch in manchen Fällen, jetzt haben wir doch nochmal die Wahlcomputer, als vielleicht auch mal sein zu lassen aus bestimmten grundsätzlichen Erwägungen. Ja und vielleicht verbessert sich so etwas. Wir werden sehen. Ich würde sagen, wir haben es. Das war Chaosradio Express 66. Politik für Anfänger, Politik für Nerds, das war hier so unser Thema, der Versuch mal ein bisschen zusammenzuhaken, was eigentlich so auf der Straße liegt. Ich denke, es gibt hier einfach eine ganze Menge. Es muss einfach etwas entgegengesetzt werden, diesem Genöle, so dieses ach ja, also nicht so dieses die da oben, aber so dieses Ferne, oh Gott, jetzt habt ihr schon wieder das Falsche. Das Falsche entschieden und das, obwohl ich mich zwei Jahre später dann noch dagegen ausgesprochen habe. Man muss einfach vorneweg sein, so gerade wenn man irgendwie selber meint, für die Zukunft zu stehen, dann müsste man eigentlich den anderen immer um zwei Jahre voraus sein.
Man kann sich es bequem machen, man kann sich in seinen Sessel zurücklegen, den Laptop auf dem Schoß haben und sagen, die da oben, alle böse, alle Verschwörungen und sonst was. Häufig ist es nur fehlende Information und daran lässt sich arbeiten.
Was war deine These mit den Verschwörungstheorien?
Ich sage immer, man braucht keine Verschwörungstheorien, wenn Menschen auch schon so doof genug sein können.
Okay, also ihr seht, da ist noch eine Menge zu holen. Ich hoffe, ihr engagiert euch alle sofort. Und ja, das war's jetzt. Chaosradio Express, vielen Dank Falk. Und wir hören uns bald wieder. Dieses Mal wäre ich sogar noch mehr als sonst interessiert am Feedback, um vielleicht auch einfach mal das Thema Politik bei Chaosradio Express festzuhalten. Ich habe da auf jeden Fall noch den einen oder anderen Gesprächspartner im Sinne, mit dem ich das nochmal weiter vertiefen möchte in bestimmte Dinge. Heute sind wir nochmal sehr allgemein rangegangen. Das war auch Sinn und Zweck der Übung. Die üblichen Kanäle Chaosradio erzählt cc.de für E-Mail oder schaut einfach mal aufs Blog. Es gibt zu jeder Sendung einen Eintrag, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de Wir möchten hören, was ihr denkt und dann schauen wir nochmal, ob wir irgendwas verbessern können, oder? Okay, das war's.